it's I am absolutely in support of basic
research product development happening
in private Enterprises to see that
there's a Marketplace for things because
once money starts coming in it funds the
next cycle and these things to kind of
keep going any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
welcome everybody to a very special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast featuring a fellow attendee of
the University of California in this
case Berkeley way up North uh and it is
uh David Friedberg who I've been a fan
of for many years he's an entrepreneur
an investor he's worked with Google he's
worked on solving the problems of
climate change he's worked in
agriculture and uh but like I said most
important thing is that he's a proud son
of the University of California uh even
if it is that one up north and not here
in San Diego David welcomed into the
impossible
thanks for having me excited to talk
yeah it's been uh it's been a great
great amount of fun kind of talking with
friends and getting them to solicit
questions uh for you and and hopefully
I'll have a fun conversation about
science about about the future of
sustainability and science about nuclear
energy about biotech uh we're gonna dive
deep because you are an astrophysics
we're an astrophysics major at Cal and
uh you I think it's probably true David
that you've probably taught more people
some really deep and beautifully
delightfully nerdy science on your
podcast which you're one of the four
besties on the all-in podcast I'm not
going to speak very much about that fair
warning full disclosure but through the
science Corner which I think we're going
to start with you have really brought to
light to the masses to millions of
people your podcast is one of the most
popular in the whole world
um really deep dives into things like
fusion decarbonization and most recently
you've taught you know probably 10
million people what uh what ribosomes do
for a living so the first question I
want to ask you is what what drives your
curiosity what what kinds of things spur
your curiosity that then become a you
know part of the science Corner what
kind of things does it take to get your
attention on a scientific topic
I don't know I mean I have a lot of
subscriptions to journals
um you know I they all come to my inbox
every week and I kind of scroll through
articles then there's certain topics
that I tend to have kind of deep Dives
in where I'm spending time on something
uh and then something it kind of catches
my interest and I go deeper on it and
further on it and then
um you know all of a sudden I come
across something that I'm like holy crap
does the world know about this this is
amazing and I feel like sometimes I talk
about it I will say like on the science
corner on our podcast I very rarely get
to talk about the things I want to talk
about or talk about them as much as I'd
like to talk about them I feel like we
barely scratch the surface on the awe
and wonderment of the universe and all
that's out there and all that people
should be thinking about and not the
humbling nature of the discoveries made
through scientific Endeavor
um so yeah I mean it's um it's great to
share some of those moments with people
and and and you know get people
intrigued and whatnot but
um man we uh we we live really uh just
at the the surface of the lake uh if you
will yeah it is yeah I mean yeah a lot a
lot of papers a lot of research a lot of
blogs a lot of yeah whatever I can kind
of come across books Etc you mentioned
journal and then a size by the way like
like I I will say like speaking to
scientists they'll often make
recommendations on folks and then you
read these books and takes you down a
whole nother Rabbit Hole yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna send you some books that I
think you'll enjoy or at least will cure
your insomnia yeah because they're my
books but but no there are other books
I'd love to get uh get your eyeballs on
um so you mentioned journals you
subscribe to journals um I got into
trouble recently on Twitter because I
tweeted out that you know peer review is
the worst form of scientific fact
checking except for all the others you
know kind of aping Winston Churchill's
uh sober K on Democracy
um what do you think about peer review I
I know you're you're Forte especially is
obviously you're trained in physics
astrophysics but you have this special
Panache for for biotech and biology and
we'll get to that in great depth later
but
um on the subject of peer review what
what do you think of the replication
crisis the you know kind of pay to play
journals what do you see is the future
or what would you do differently than
peer review if anything
yeah I know a lot of people want to see
these kind of decentralized models
emerge I hope that there's more
experimentation around them and that
they and that there is some resolution I
don't love the fact that these journals
charge these subscription fees and that
they're really you know you have to get
in a name brand journal in order to get
recognition I think that um you know a
lot of the pre-print
um uh publishing uh Opera options are a
really great way to get started but I
would say that there's probably
one thing that's super critical
um that's lacking which is there's often
an amplification of something maybe a
little early in the cycle of It kind of
achieving some degree of consensus let's
use the word consensus because there
should never be absolute consensus in
science so as you make progress uh
towards having greater consensus uh
maybe there's a moment at which point it
makes sense to have some amplification
and often we see these kind of
pre-prints that maybe aren't replicable
get a ton of amplification they become
kind of Mainstay they become accepted
that becomes fact and then anything
against it is you know hey you're
disputing fact you're disputing science
um so one of the things that I think is
deeply missing in the amplifiers uh
whether they're Twitter people or
journalists or what have you is a kind
of a better sense of scientific literacy
um and the ability to kind of interpret
scientific data and results
and then recognize that that data and
results that can and should change under
maybe different conditions or should be
demonstrated by other testers
um because often I'll see someone pick
something out of a paper uh or they'll
miss the real point of the data and
they'll say something that maybe isn't
quite true or they'll jump on amplifying
something that isn't quite there yet
um
so uh certainly from from a from a
process perspective we need to kind of
get
scientific literacy rates and and have a
peer review system that isn't contingent
on this kind of uh commercial piping
where you kind of uh you know have to
pay to get access uh to the right
journals and then you have to pay to get
access to the content in those journals
it's it's all you know science should be
open uh the data should be open and
there should be kind of a much more
free-for-all open source voting process
to support these things what form that
takes I don't have a strong opinion I
haven't spent much time thinking about
it I know that there's lots of different
ideas out there yeah one idea that's
been floated by you know uh hopefully
future guests on the podcast former UCSD
Professor Andrew huberman you know is
like nfts and science you know where you
uh you know you pay uh you know to the
Friedberg microscope and you look down
and you get the first you know picture
of some you know the next thing you're
going to dump into uh into a super gut I
don't know I'm just making this up but
but the point is you could use an nft
model uh to support signs what do you
think about that kind of suggestion and
could you see that you know reverting
back to to the patronage of the medicis
and could you see a downside of that
potentially
yeah I don't know that that's a little
quirky to me um
because I think it implies decentralized
funding I don't think you need
decentralized funding like you know all
these systems of decentralized Networks
um they're not necessarily the best way
to solve a problem like
um you know if you remember back in the
day Skype was like a peer-to-peer like
communication system and the latency was
high and the a lot of bits were lost
along the way and so Skype didn't end up
winning right like zoom and and Google
meet and Microsoft teams won because
they had a more robust centralized
Network model that worked uh the data
would be transmitted to the center of
the network and more efficiently routed
back to the uh to the consumer and same
with a company called Juiced which made
this peer-to-peer video sharing and I
think uh um Kaza and Napster all these
peer-to-peer systems were less efficient
um they're kind of trying to solve a
problem uh in the least efficient way or
in a less efficient way than maybe a
centralized model so I don't think that
it's about decentralized funding I think
it's about
um you know we can aggregate more money
through a central Source like some
federal grants or
um or what have you uh there's another
interesting model I'll share in a minute
which is um
kind of private Enterprises that can
aggregate large pools of capital and
then allocate them within that pool uh
in a way uh that maybe has smarter
Capital allocators than and and a faster
turnaround time on allocating Capital
than say a government Source the problem
with decentralized networks is often you
see
um adverse selection uh you see this in
like the insurance industry the term is
often used the adverse selection where
um it's the best Storyteller that wins
not necessarily the best candidate uh
and so we saw this with like
um you know all these icos these the
initial coin offerings or even with FTX
uh it's easy to take advantage of people
it's easy to take advantage of a
distributed network of funders versus
having someone who has the criteria and
the ability to kind of screen things in
a smarter way uh than say um a lot of
people who then get drawn into some uh
story and then they they lose a lot of
money and things don't go well so I'm
not sold on the decentralized funding
model as much as I am on just
um you know having more transparency and
functioning around how do we fund things
through centralized aggregated pools of
capital yeah and to that extent there
there's a lot of the you know Journal
kind of peer review process that's you
know resembles the academic proposal and
grant writing process in that it's not
transparent there's no feedback I just
had a young student brilliant young man
and he applied for a fellowship and they
actually wanted him to apply for this
Fellowship uh and he just got summarily
rejected and he got no feedback and and
at least with the journals or you know
system them you do get feedback there
are at least two people that typically
will review I've been a reviewer for
Nature and Science and all these
journals and there's usually at least
two people but not much more than that
and at the proposal level it's much
worse even and and that sort of makes me
want to Pivot although you did say did
you had another model that you wanted to
suggest or uh in that front or is that
is that part well you know there's a
there's a there's a group there's a
group that got funded last year called
Altos last they raised about three
billion dollars in startup funding and
they're pursuing
um this kind of uh uh epigenetic partial
uh reprogramming uh of um of cells uh to
make them more youthful right these
yamanaka factors which won the the Nobel
Prize the number of years ago
demonstrated the ability to kind of uh
right uh induce pluripotent stem cells
uh from any cell so you can kind of
apply these factors and they are kind of
uh rewrite the epigenome of the cell and
the cell starts to act like a plural
stem cell and it turns out that what's
being called partial reprogramming
allows the cell to act more youthful and
and kind of resets the epigenome not all
the way to being a stem cell but to
being the type of cell it is and as a
result that and and that cell actually
starts to function more effectively so
it's kind of this uh youthful indicators
are through the roof it's really an
incredible
um set of demonstrations it often ends
up causing cancer however uh because
these cells some of the cells go all the
way to being stem cells and then they
start proliferating uncontrollably and
you have these kind of cancer problems
um so it's a it's a very difficult kind
of bioengineering problem to figure out
how we're going to make this work
therapeutically so this company um Altos
Labs got stood up I think they raised
three billion dollars from Bob Nelson
who's like one of the best biotech
investors in the world and Yuri Milner
and Jeff Bezos a lot of people put money
in and they've been going out and just
grabbing some of the best academic and
research teams out there that are like
they brought a ton of people out from
UCSF and I think part of the pitch to
them was look you guys can make a decent
salary working here and you don't need
to go through this multi-year grant
writing process we have good smart
Capital allocators we'll make very quick
decisions at the top everyone will see
it it'll all be very open and
transparent you'll get this funding and
then your team and your work can
continue to do their research and 100 of
the IP will be owned by the holding
company and right now all the IP would
technically be owned by UC or UCSF in
this case now it's going to be held by
this holding company but the benefit to
the research team to the scientists is
you get very fast turnaround times you
don't have to wait you don't have to
kind of you know get dolled out little
small checks here and there from these
grants spending a 30-year time writing
grants and then you know reporting back
in in a way that allows you to get your
next Grant and maybe doing things that
are a little bit um disincentivizing so
um I think it's a really interesting
model I'm really curious to see what
comes out of Alto slabs given that the
number of teams that they've gone out
and like vacuumed up from Academia the
probability of that portfolio of teams
having a breakthrough or a set of
breakthroughs that has commercial
success is very high
um and so it's enough Capital to give
you enough shots on goal that one of
these things will work one of these
teams will come up with something that
you can kind of develop and then they
own 100 of it instead of going to UCSF
and trying to negotiate an I.T license
and waiting years for that and so on
um which I think is the traditional
model of these biotech companies getting
set up right and I look at that and I
contrast it with you know basic physics
the kind of research I do which is also
you know becoming more and more
supported by private foundations my
Observatory that I co-lead is called the
Simons Observatory after Cal grad Jim
Simons uh long-term supporter of
cosmology and basic science as well as
autism and and uh many other fields but
he's often criticized you know like well
what's this privatization of Science and
basic you know it should be free
everything should be free and aren't
these billionaires just going to get
whatever they want I mean you hear Bill
Gates criticized uh incessantly for the
work that you know kind of I wonder in
in and that's in cosmology you know what
I'm doing or you know Jim Simons is
supporting you know just just personally
um or you know the team not me
personally but but the point being
um in a field like biotech where you
have you know implications on human
health and you have you know the risks
in human subjects volunteering is there
a risk of you know the privatization
kind of attracting you know really The
Unwanted attention you know the you
didn't build this kind of ethos that
well yeah you're just coming in and
screaming skimming the cream off the top
after these universities public
universities have put so much into it
and how is it fair that some
billionaires can you know profiteer off
of this so what what do you how would
you answer such critics
okay so I'm a big believer in the
efficiency of markets and a market has a
buyer and a seller and if a buyer is
willing to pay what a seller wants for
something
um a transaction will take place
um and so you have to have
um a market and uh where there are
buyers and sellers coming together
uh for things to sustain themselves
otherwise they're being force-fed and
they're not real so you know we'll talk
about this I think a little bit later
but the term sustainability for me I
think needs to be thought about in the
context of how sustainable is this
sustainability Endeavor and sustainable
meaning how much will the market support
it without some massive intervention uh
driving it because otherwise it's not
what the customer wants it's not what
the buyers want it's what some side of
the market is trying to push into the
market and they're subsidizing it or
reducing the price and so those are all
really bad things and on the flip side
if they're holding things back that the
market wants to buy that's also really
bad if the sellers aren't willing to
sell what the market wants to buy
so I am all for private Enterprises and
people allocating their own capital and
having hundreds or thousands or millions
of businesses and entrepreneurs coming
up with ideas bringing them to the
market seeing if there's buyers and
investing capital and making those
Pursuits I am absolutely in support of
basic research product development
happening in private Enterprises to see
that there is a Marketplace for things
because once money starts coming in it
funds the next cycle and these things to
kind of keep going
now in in the academic and government
sense
um
if there's there are some early stage
efforts in in pure science and research
that are unfundable from a capital
markets perspective
because the time Horizons are too far
out and the uncertainty is too great
and it you know you have to spend a
hundred billion dollars or 20 billion
dollars and then maybe you have a five
percent chance at a breakthrough I mean
look at how much the uh the the Eye Care
Facility right in France is I think it's
a 30 billion dollars at this point there
is no Marketplace to support that
um there is no I look I'm a donor uh to
Lick Observatory at uh at UC uh Alex
villampenco who you may know
um and and and yeah and so I am uh you
know very much in support of funding uh
pure science there's a lot of work
that's gone on UCSF one of the
advantages UCSF has uh for example is
they also have access to a patient
Community where they can get incredible
data
um and uh and get infield very quickly
so so they do have an advantage in being
able to kind of generate new science any
discoveries the challenge arises that
that um science then either gets
licensed out in a way that UC doesn't
benefit enough from the discovery that
was made where they own the IP
um or they're just not open sourcing it
those are the two problems and what
happens often is something in the middle
and that thing in the middle is where
like you end up with some guy who thinks
he's too smart and he's the licensing
guy and he goes out and he tries to
negotiate one deal with and you know the
smart VC comes to him and he takes him
to dinner and drinks and he's like okay
I'll take six percent of your company
and you get the license to mistake six
percent of the company for the IP UC
should own 100 on day one and then the
VCS should kind of compete for who's
willing to pay what to get access to
that IP there's no competitive auction
model
um there's no model that really
maximizes the value of the IP that was
generated by UC in that case or a
research institution that's one way is
that the research institution can either
maximize the value for the investment
that they're making and if they did and
they could capture a piece of that there
would be incredible Returns the Cystic
Fibrosis Foundation funded a biotech
startup that did peer research uh came
through with a breakthrough therapeutic
that company sold the royalties and the
license on that and Cystic Fibrosis
Foundation I think netted three billion
dollars or something out of this outcome
um and I think that's the model that the
academics and the research institutions
should be taking which is maximizing
value and doing it in a way that's
really structured so it's an auction
it's a it's a market-based model versus
one guy kind of you know and I've tried
to license stuff from universities I
I've tried from Harvard from MIT from
the UCSF and I got to tell you all these
guys operate differently it's impossible
to get through to anyone
um it's impossible to Wrangle these
things out VIP just kind of sits there
in languishes they have these incredible
breakthroughs they publish on them and
then you as an enterprising business
that's willing to put a billion dollars
behind it to bring it to Market make it
real can't get access to it and when you
do get access to it where someone gets
access to it they're usually an Insider
who gets a good deal on it right and
then the university doesn't benefit as
much as they should the other
alternative is to just open source
everything and that's another way to say
look the government's going to fund or
the university is going to fund x
billion dollars over this amount of time
and everything that comes out is
available to everyone
um and and let them Market proliferate
and figure out how do you take that IP
forward and build businesses on top of
it I think both of those models can work
the problem is we have a model that kind
of doesn't provide yeah we have the
Schrodinger's uh model uh just to push
back with uh love and respect so we have
an exchange of you know capital for
labor you know here and it resulted in a
strike a very well publicized strike at
the University of California including
up there Cal and down here in San Diego
and graduate students and postdocs and
kind of the lifeblood of the University
went on strike essentially saying you
know that their contract was unfair and
yes they people had agreed to uh you
know to sell something and there was a
willing buyer and a willing seller but
no more and I wonder you know maybe
pivoting that to to this notion that
well okay so if capitalism is the best
system uh you know then scientific
capitalism it's always going to rely on
labor at some level now the the problem
I had with the graduate students much I
love them and they do become part of
your family I mean I had my graduates
semi-graduate students at my wedding
um you know I've been to to you know
funerals of people that were my mentors
so it's very familial and the strike
kind of brought some possible enmity
between what should be kind of like a
family I notice I'm rambling a little
bit but but the point being when you
have Labor that is also getting an
education and getting training and
getting professional development unlike
medical students right who go into debt
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars is there like kind of an what
are the obligations say of the of the
researchers that are you know some cases
in biology they do get kind of exploited
in physics it's much less so we have to
pay basically the the rate of the
highest you know NASA Fellowship to get
a postdoc here but what are the
obligations of of the laborers if you
like in science at the academic level
versus The MENTOR they or the capital
class versus the labor class if I know
it's not a Perfect Analogy but what
would you see is the as the obligations
we're all in the same you know effort to
try to benefit scientific knowledge but
what are the obligations of say the
student researcher class versus the pi
class
um now who should benefit as well you
know should the graduate student who
makes this discovery that gets monetized
and the Pi's name is on the patent you
know what are the obligations as well as
the the responsibilities yeah there's a
there's an important question there also
as it relates to like athletes in in
universities right there's been a lot of
controversy lately on the NCAA and
athletes can't take endorsements and
it's kind of a similar model where
you're you're given
uh more than just the salary
um
it's look this is a broader
philosophical question what is someone
who gets to be a doctor get versus
someone
who you know has another job that maybe
isn't as fulfilling or rewarding to them
um you know there's an element of why
people take the job of being a teacher
when it doesn't pay as much because it's
rewarding uh and and
um it's it's what they want to do with
their time and with their life
um and I think that there's an important
kind of judgment call about you know
what someone wants to get out of a job
and it's often not just the salary it's
the salary plus
um and the plus I think if it's enough
uh uh to make up for the Delta on salary
relative to other Alternatives or other
or expectations
um
it's uh it kind of gets you there
um but I think you I'll come back to
your other question in a second um I I
view like unions to be almost like
startups it's like if the entire
organization is dependent on the labor
and without the labor the organization
doesn't work then the labor is the
company the laborer is the startup and
service yes the quote students as a
service yeah the shareholder yeah and
and that's exactly what it is and by the
way in the model of kind of
decentralized Worlds decentralized
networks we do see this concept of
instead of everyone working for a
company or working for a thing everyone
works for themselves and then they can
plug in and out of different things that
they work for
um and it's an individual as a service
provider instead of a group of people as
an employee base and that also creates a
more efficient market where kind of
individuals find themselves the the
bigger issue with with unions generally
um I think it works well in a market it
works well for the late laborers where
there is almost a commoditization of the
labor like everyone working on a factory
line but like I've been on the board of
the SF Symphony and there's a union for
the uh the members of the orchestra
obviously in universities graduates
units are not all created equal and
um you know I think that that
the idea of having a union there
um you know it's uh it it can kind of
work against some people in that market
um I do think one of the ways to resolve
that salary plus Gap is to create a
model where you do share the IP value
with the the research team or the
discovery team that worked on something
let them participate in ultimately the
commercial success of that out of that
output again if there was a really great
engine at all of these government or
academic Labs that publish in an open
source way the IP they wouldn't benefit
but if it was like a bid model and
anytime the uip came to Market within
six months it's going to be an auction
people can come in they can bid on the
IP they can get access to it and it
doesn't have to be this kind and I know
that's a little naive because all the
IPS clustered in different ways and it
comes out in in a long line of stuff
over time and so on so universities it
can get very complex in what IP you're
licensing and how but to have a value
share model with the the research team
may solve that salary Gap problem yeah
but as you know then you have the
problem where some researchers aren't
putting out IP that industry wants to
license right you know if you're working
in anthropology there's not going to be
a lot of value coming out of your lab
versus if you're working in peer physics
or even in physics I have two patents
they've never made me a penny and Elon I
know has said you know patents are
basically lawsuit bait
um and you know physics there's there's
precious little you know as opposed to
biotech where it's like you basically
since you know there's a lawyer in your
laboratory uh none of my colleagues
Laboratories and maybe that's a sign
they're doing more useful research than
than uh you know pure astrophysics but
but anyway continue yeah
look I I um
I'm not sure like the right answer on
the the graduates get a strike and you
know whether they have an obligation uh
to do research I think for them if the
benefit of the work and the benefit they
get from doing the work plus the salary
they make isn't enough like any human
they're gonna want to look for other
things or try and make up the Gap so I
don't know it just seems like a pretty
natural
kind of marketplace Dynamic to me uh so
you know we see it we see it everywhere
yeah so pivoting uh just back to Pure
science for a second just taking a
question from one of my audience members
uh that that's been submitted to me uh
so Leif wants to know what question in
science would David give his right arm
to know the answer to it
what material will superconduct at room
temperature ah awesome okay great so
that that I think you know as as folks
that are probably listening know you
know um
uh super conducting material has has no
resistance and has this ability to kind
of be a perfect
um magnetic field reflector and uh it's
long been theorized uh and as you know
there's there's several theories for how
we get there that we should be able to
to realize some sort of structure or
some sort of molecule or some sort of
um uh ceramic or something that can
actually superconduct at room
temperature because the cost of cooling
makes uh superconducting materials uh
you know not very extensible right we
could reduce the loss of uh electricity
and transmission lines uh we could
create levitating cranes and reduce
friction and energy needs for
transportation I mean the applications
you know the incredible applications in
Computing
um you know imagine having uh uh you
know the equivalent of a quantum
computer in your in your iPhone like I
mean there's just so much that that
could be realized if we can get a
material that's superconduct at room
temperature and there's all these phonon
pairing theories and uh not a lot that's
been proved and or disproven really at
this stage and it's like we always kind
of walk a little bit halfway closer to
the wall uh and no one knows how or why
we're getting where we're going right
but that's a that's a really exciting
area I mean I was 13 years old I had a
science fair project at school and I did
it on superconductors and I actually got
the superconducting disk from from UCLA
couple bucks or something and some
liquid nitrogen from UCLA imported in
and did a magnet floated it I said and I
have my board and I said here's all the
things you're going to be able to do
with superconductors in the future and
it's going to totally change the world
and we're going to have you know it
started with this Atrium barium copper
oxide ceramic and then everything is
going to change and you know um here we
are I was 13 how old am I now I'm 42 so
you know 30 years later
um and not much has changed but yeah
that would be my big question yeah it's
uh certainly fascinating I always point
out you know superconductivity is the
one problem that could have been solved
by Feynman that he basically failed to
solve it was solved by my uh graduate
student uh one of my graduate school
professors Leon Cooper and bardeen and
and shreefer who uh Sharif yeah Cooper
pairing that's right Leon is still alive
and kicking I saw him back in May when I
spoke at Brown University commencement
and uh he's uh he's a character but um
pivoting to to schriefer who is one of
his uh co-laureates uh so schreifer won
the Nobel Prize twice
um and he was first Nobel Prize he won
it with uh was with William Shockley it
was uh that is in of the Bay Area and
one of the founders of all uh it's fair
title yeah Fairchild semiconductor which
then the traitorous uh eight I think it
was called uh by him including Gordon
Moore went off and started uh T.I and
then um Intel but I want to bring up uh
Shockley not for his uh you know kind of
reprehensible eugenicist ideas and and
stuff involving the Nobel Prize sperm
bank which he allegedly contributed to
down here in San Diego County
um but but instead on the transistor
that you know he co-invented and is
responsible for us having this
conversation there's about 10 billion
transistors on each side of uh of our
screens uh just alone
um and the fact that he and and
basically all you know I've interviewed
in 14 Nobel laureates and I've asked
them you know maybe sort of questions
along this this front but I think you're
um not Nobel Laureate but you I think in
the in the realm of sustainability and
and kind of financial remuneration look
it's important to scientists everyone
says as I would do it if I didn't get
the prize and I'd do it if I didn't get
the money and I believe them but the
fact is David that there's not a single
Nobel Prize winner in any field maybe
economics I don't even think so I
interviewed Widow in Benz at Stanford
across the bay from you and he uh and he
said you know basically he did it for
the fun of it not for the money but
anyway there's not a single Laureate to
my knowledge that died with a net worth
greater than 10x of his mostly his Nobel
Prize winnings
um which and and some are in fact we're
almost destitute by medical illnesses
Liam Letterman
um uh who is an experimental particle
physicist he had to sell his dumbbell
prize to fund his dementia treatments
and and Alzheimer's treatments uh Watson
James Watson I think sold his for
several million dollars for fun in other
words these Nobel laureates are
responsible for Pure technology for for
great discoveries DNA the transistor the
laser Charlie towns who I knew uh
briefly at your alma mater
um yeah he invented a laser which is you
know contributes a trillion dollars
every year to world GDP died again not
not destitute but how do you envision or
how could we envision a model where
physics could be sustainable and that
the physicist you do contribute could
receive financial remuneration is there
is there a kind of a Marketplace
solution
um to the problem of sustainability in
other words that we we should we tax
every email you know 0.1 cents or every
web uh you know hyperlink that's clicked
because it was a CERN byproduct
um do you have any thoughts on this day
but how we could make a sustainable I
mean we already yeah nft I don't think
that's a starter in many for many
reasons but can you think of ways that
we can make it sustainable and
remunerative to the uh could the
inventor class
I um I just want to challenge the notion
that the one thing is the value crater
for the whole of the market that the
laser is the trillion dollar market
um and I'll say it like this that there
there is
um
this this kind of um Motif that there's
this rock star entrepreneur who builds a
business and makes all this money and
the reality is that that individual
is a small member of a very large team
that is tackling a very large set of
problems on a daily basis using a lot of
capital to get there to figure out how
do you build a business and create a
value great great market value and
create a product
and that whole team is dedicating their
lives to the work and that will and all
the capital that went in came from
Pension funds and retirement funds
because it's managed you know that's
what VCS typically manage and and so on
and so forth or or it's like large
investors that are mutual funds that are
putting money in the public company when
you play this all out we all think that
it's an individual running across the
field and then they got right the
idolatry events
it's a it's a rugby Scrump okay and the
Rugby scrum is pushing the ball down the
field trying to get this thing in the
other end before they get their heads up
that's the reality of like building
products and building businesses in a
Marketplace and I the the unfortunate
reality of being a human is our brains
are wired in such a way that we all
think that we're the outsized
contributor to that success I I elbowed
that guy in the head I took him out
that's how you got to the end zone only
three people can win the Nobel Prize
right yeah
exactly and the Nobel Prize problem is
the same problem in entrepreneurship and
in scientific research and um I'll give
you kind of a
um I'll I'll say two things one both
Kanye West and Taylor Swift complained
about the fact that they sold all of
these original uh tracks that they had I
forgot with the Masters yeah uh to the
record label at the time that each of
them sold their their their masters to
the record label they were struggling
emerging artists and they said for
giving up all of my future rights to
this music it may or may not work and
that moment we had no idea what would
come with that music and the record
label took a risk and they put a bunch
of money in their pockets and Kanye and
Taylor Swift said oh my God it just that
money just changed my life yeah they
sold it so happened to me they sold some
call up yeah it just so happened exactly
and then the record label happened to
make a ton of money and then they come
back and they're like wait wait I want
more of that money and all the artists
that lost that the the record label
spent money on that didn't work out they
don't get to come back and demand a lot
of money because their music didn't work
out and they got paid and the record
label lost money the record label
doesn't get to go to those artists and
say give me back my money your music
didn't sell right
um and I use that as an example not to
be this capitalist pig or to be
disparaging but the reality is number
one we don't know what's going to work
ultimately
um and number two is there's a scrum to
get there there's so much that goes into
I mean think about the original
transistor how much does the original
transistor look like the 10 billion it's
the code hanger David it's a code hanger
with some chicken wire and then there's
a piece of chewing gum in there always
look I'll put we'll put a clip wrap here
in the in the video that if you're
watching on YouTube yeah and I and I've
like I I can't tell you how many people
I've sat at dinner with or at a poker
table with or had drinks with or sat
next to an airplane and everyone said I
had that idea I came up with that thing
and it was the thing that someone else
turned into a big business and even when
you have the same thing you can give the
same IP or the same technology or the
same thing to 10 different entrepreneurs
or ten different businesses or 10
different investors and nine of them
won't work and maybe one of them will
work so you never know what path what
team and what it's going to take to take
a concept or a discovery or an invention
and make it into a business that
generates money and 99 of the value
unfortunately comes from that business
building exercise because that's where
the scrum happens right that's where
you're hiring and firing people burning
money iterating on product markets
they're trying to figure out what
customers want taking that original coat
hanger and turning it into this
incredible LCD monitor that costs
fifteen hundred dollars that I can sit
in front of today and talk to you
through the air it's like you know what
it took how many people it took to go
from that to this how much money you
took yeah you know and as much as I
think that that invention is a really
like powerful moment of a breakthrough
it is the guy in the coffee shop with
the napkin that has the idea and then
the other guy goes and builds the
e-commerce site and or 15 guys take that
idea and 14 of them fail and the one guy
builds it the guy with the napkin you
know he had a great idea of but ninety
percent of the 99 of the value is so
it's hard to say foreign I don't believe
in this whole thing about glorifying
either the entrepreneur or the idea
person and I you know I hate this idea
of the term founder frankly there are so
many quote Founders in Silicon Valley
Who start a company and then they're not
there when the company ultimately
figures out its product or when the
company ultimately starts making money
or finds a customer or goes public and
like from the first 20 people to the
next 20 000 people it's a completely
different work instead of it's a
completely different company it's a
completely different skill set different
skill set and 20 000 people worked on it
for ten years yeah and those 20 000
people that worked on it for 10 years
all contributed time and all these
investors contributed money so you know
for me it's not about like how do we you
know uh get get things back I do think
that we need to make sure that IP rights
end up in the right way that there's a
Marketplace to get these things going
and get people to participate and all
the universities are you know Caltech
has a friend of mine
um runs a VC at Cal Tech and it's like
all it's all about bringing Caltech uh
uh physicists and biologists out into
the market twice and giving them
ownership of their IP and they've got a
great licensing deal with Caltech so
they can take that IP transferred into
startups and then they can go and build
their business yeah
and make me an equity and ownership yeah
across the country the other school with
the beaver mascot in addition to my fair
beloved uh Caltech where I was a postdoc
uh for a few years as MIT and they have
the Bose uh you know the Bose family of
those sound products and medical
products and so forth they have this you
know their MIT is one of their biggest
uh you know effective shareholders I I
wouldn't know how you describe it but
part of the problem is you know I always
say that you know one of the main
challenges for someone doing fundamental
physics is that are fundamental science
of any kind is that sometimes it
produces technology you know and so then
people really have this expectation that
you're you know you're the goose that's
going to keep laying these these golden
eggs and as you said there there's a
completely different you know kind of um
toolkit to get from you know One
customer or just the Prototype the you
know the chewing gum and and the coat
hanger to the LCD monitor
um at the same time I remember listening
to a talk by Jim Simons again you know
grad proud grad of of Cal yeah and he
you know and he said um you know he
famously runs one of the most profitable
hedge funds in history it might even be
the most profitable one
um Renaissance Technologies and he said
you know for a second yeah yeah right
now it's uh Griffin right uh but uh but
he said you know for a long time they
famously only hired phds and it was only
like astrophysics I sent somebody you
know students to heaven and he would
review them yeah but now they don't do
that anymore because they found that
like they they don't know anything about
business it's a very different skill
that I found even with
yes you know in my in my spare time
which is which is so lovely I get to
talk to so many brilliant people
including including um yourself uh and
it's really brought a lot of joy to me
but it's a completely different
um skill set and I'm sure you know that
like there's no skill set there's no job
description podcaster right I mean it's
a billion micro skills and I don't think
we do a great job of teaching you know
there's no job there's no single job
Professor I mean I have like 80
different things from t-shirt research
teaching research the fundraising you
know Outreach but oftentimes David the
the kind of non-you know technical lab
work
um you know grunge work in the lab is if
you don't do that you're kind of looked
down upon uh when I wrote my first book
losing the Nobel Prize I went in to ask
my department chair who was the son of a
Nobel Prize winner who invent
co-invented the laser Nikolai bassoff
and um I said you know Dimitri can I
have some time off you know uh to write
this book he said um we won't give you
any time off but we won't explicitly
punish you for writing this book uh in
other words that this is not something
that you know that that uh a serious
scientist should be spending his or her
time on and I've had that from my friend
John 11 at Columbia and and Barnard and
other places but to what extent are we
maybe compromising the future output of
science I'll just focus on physics by by
basically ascribing maybe not the best
um you know kind of attitude or cultural
attitude towards those people that want
to monetize or want to start you know
businesses as well as be scientists in
other words we're not teaching them
those skills but we might also be
stigmatizing
um you know I don't think it's a big
secret that you know 99 of my colleagues
are you know are Democrat or very
liberal and they might look down upon
they supported the strikes and so forth
they might look down upon you know any
attempt to monetize or something like
that as being attractive to Pure physics
and the reason and they quote unquote
got into it do you see it like a benefit
to teaching entrepreneurship or you know
some kind of skill set within a physics
department
um I've seen it at a lot of places in a
generally like has not worked well
um
uh okay so why is yeah why why is there
negative attitude yeah so so my my three
biggest predictors for entrepreneurial
success are grit bias to action American
ability to kind of tell narrative so
grit is perseverance through failure
which many scientists actually do have
because most of the work you're doing is
iterating uh continuing to kind of
develop even after something fails
um bias to action is a little different
where so much of of
um you know depending on kind of what
science we're talking about uh you're
doing careful planning you don't get to
do careful planning when you're building
a startup or a growth stage business you
have to have a biased act I always tell
people the absolute index of biased
action is the movie Groundhog Day by the
way happy grounding yeah happy groundhog
because yeah yeah so you get to you get
to basically live the same if you could
live the same day a million times in a
day you could make that day perfect
um and that's what a startup is you
don't know what path is going to get you
to the other side of the mountain and
you have to get over there before you
run out of food and water and so you've
got to constantly be looking realizing
you're wrong turning around going back
realizing you're wrong turning around
going back the faster you can do that
the more of a bias you have to
responding to what the environment or
the market or your product development
cycle are telling you the more likely
you are to succeed before you right out
of capital or time
and then narrative the person who
indexes infinitely on narrative
um so so let me just say each one of
these three categories you can index
infinitely on if you index infinitely on
grit it means you will never give up
you're out of water you're out of food
you're out of money and you convince
everyone to keep going and not and not
um and you know 300 movies 300 yeah
exactly exactly that's the absolute
absolute unbiased action is the movie is
the movie Groundhog Day and the absolute
on narrative is a guy like Elon Musk uh
who could show up tell you he's gonna do
something and then not do it and still
get you to give him more money and do it
over and over again for 10 years and
then finally he delivers a product but
the ability that he has and Steve Jobs
had is this ability to storytell people
about what's possible in the future and
the power of narrative is that you can
attract employees to come and help you
build get in that scrum with you on the
Rugby field you can attract Capital
investors will keep giving you money so
you actually have more time to get there
and ability to attract customers sell
them on the vision and the dream of what
you're building and um those three skill
sets are independent skill sets of and
I'm not saying that there's no overlap
there can certainly be overlapped with
scientists that are working in Academia
but I'm saying those are the skill sets
that that predict entrepreneurial
success and there's a real question on
how much of that comes learned through
behavior and experience how much of it
is innate and how much of it can be
taught
um and that's where I think there's a
challenge of like let me just throw up
an entrepreneurship school and teach
people how to be entrepreneurs I think
that these the these things that are
necessary for entrepreneurship all the
rest of it's tactical it's textbook
stuff it's like do this write this plan
you know you know find your customer
like there's a lot of people that help
and support entrepreneurship and
development but without those three
things they're having a strong index on
some set of those three things I think
um you know the probability of success
is generally very low yeah
um and so that's why I think these
things are really hard to kind of find
yeah they're hard to find and then
there's also the kind of um you know
check your own kind of uh sunk cost
fallacies and biases too because
everything you described described you
know the systematic you know behavior of
someone like Elizabeth Holmes right I
mean good Storyteller lots of grit hard
work uh bias to action you know
influential customer seeking
um and you couldn't get like I said a
better story uh and that that brings me
to my you know I was going to ask you
you know kind of another frivolous
question but but I'd like to know you
know kind of um in terms of in terms of
how you systematize your ray dalio is
famous he has a quote that you know you
should have uh you should you should a
good entrepreneur in his case he's
saying should have many things that he
systematizes or she systematizes very
well and I wanted to ask you
um you know what things in your strategy
in your investment strategy or the way
your thought process is do you
strategize in the mold of that famous
black turtleneck wearing entrepreneur
inventor Elizabeth Holmes uh so are
there things you know do you have like a
routine do you have a daily routine do
you have you know uh are you monitoring
things how do you system what what do
you systematize and what's your rubric
for systemization if you will
of the work idea yeah the work you do
and also I'd be interested in your
personal you know habits if you want to
share them
like sleep and things like that but but
then yeah into investment yeah
my um
my challenge is probably one of um
orientation towards creativity so I
biased towards creativity so if I'm not
feeling like I'm endeavoring into a
newer into a new space like I have
almost like an interest or an addiction
for new things for a new space
um it you know maybe there's this
intellectual curiosity problem that
drives me to do that but it's it's
coupled with this idea that I have to
make stuff or enable the making of stuff
too
um and so that makes it hard to have
um although someone did once tell me who
actually wrote a book on the psychology
of creativity that um having a system
for creativity can actually enable more
creativity than having the absence where
a lot of people want to kind of have the
absence of having a framework having a
painting size right those are
constraints the constraint model yeah
yeah so look I mean my world is fairly
um I mean if I were to kind of try and
classify it I've got companies that I'm
an investor in or that I helped start
that I'm an investor so I own stakes and
companies that I'm involved in
and um they have different need States
and they are very Dynamic and as their
needs States kind of
increase I need to spend more time with
them and that's why it's it's not as
easy as just every week I check in with
each one sometimes I don't need to spend
time with them sometimes there's a
crisis and I gotta spend all week with
one of them and then the work I can help
them do is either recruiting or raising
capital or product and strategy and
customer stuff
um and so that's kind of spending time
with with companies then the other one
is making sure that I have adequate
Capital to do the work I want to do so
you know we raise capital from other
investors and we use that Capital to
um to support the work we're doing and
then the third is the most the most
interesting which is kind of exploration
of New Opportunities an exploration of
New Opportunities is all about thesis
development so um
I tell people like our job is to connect
the dots uh where we spend time reading
uh papers or meeting with Scientists or
academics or researchers or engineers
then we separately spend time with
interesting Executives or entrepreneurs
and we separately spend time in the
markets understanding the markets the
businesses that are operating in these
markets very deeply and then if we can
see a connection like if you took this
engineering capability in this
scientific discovery and you put them
together with this team you could change
that market in that way and that's the
kind of connections that we try and make
which is what are we seeing the
connections between that other people
maybe aren't seeing and that then forms
the basis of a thesis that thesis can
then go be tested or invested against
um and so we would then deploy Capital
into an existing team because they map
to our thesis uh and then they can go
and kind of test it or they're executing
well against a thesis and we want to
support them and fund them or we can
help kind of build a team and start a
company to go execute against that
thesis so that's kind of
um how I would classify how I spend my
time yeah it's a system it's a
scientific method you're basically
applying the scientific method approach
to it I want to ask you I've interviewed
a few billionaires on the podcast Jim
Simons Michael Saylor Tom bilyeu and
others uh unicorn Founders and hedge
fund you know all different all
different types of personalities and I
always like to ask them you know from
your effective what what is the purpose
of wealth um you know we often remember
the original uh Wall Street movie with
Gordon Gekko and and Charlie Sheen you
know Charlie just wants to you know he's
making all this money he wants to become
wealthy so he can ride a motorcycle
across China which uh Ralph Potts is a
as a good well-known uh author podcaster
Etc and he said it costs about five
thousand dollars to drive a motorcycle
across China like in other words you
could do that right now you don't need
to become a multi-millionaire as Charlie
Sheen wanted to do and and um and Wall
Street the original one but he asked
Gordon in that movie if you remember he
asked him you know like what are you
doing all this for why are you ruining
so many lives I'm not accusing you of
that thing but um there's only so many
Yachts you can water ski behind so I
want to ask you you know in your in your
from your perception what what is the
purpose of wealth
um like I think that there's I I'm
uh I'm a Believer and I'm aligned with
this concept that humans are wired like
living organisms and you could actually
trace this back to principles of physics
are oriented around
um
uh desire that we we are we are
programmed to have this um
the Zen Buddhists talk about it as
dualism like this idea that there's
um
uh two sides to everything when in fact
they are the same okay
um or they have elements of the same
yeah the whole purpose of Buddhism is to
see
um the unity of everything and and not
what the human brain is wired to do and
we're wired in that way because we have
a body and a not body right we're wired
to see what we are and what we are not
we are wired to feel what we have and
what we have not and as a result
um we see what we have not and intend to
have more you know there's this innate
human desire that scarcity for more
yeah and and
um you know there's always something on
the other side there's always something
more
um and that's why we are successful in
the sense of kind of thermodynamics like
we're a feedback loop like we're really
good energy consumers we're really you
know and as a result we we multiply and
that that's what life is kind of
predicted around
um and so on that premise I think that
there are three kind of intangibles
that humans
um desire in a way that's fairly
unconstrained
um one is a Fame which is recognition
the other one is influence and the third
is Is wealth or assets uh whether that's
food or money or or whatever
um and so that's more like you know um
how much stuff do I have and those three
things are
um they can be traded for one another
like if you have a lot of influence uh
you can get paid by people to influence
a group of people right you're you could
definition of an influencer
um you know if if you have a lot of Fame
um you know you can turn that into money
right you can get paid to do things
um uh if you have a lot of money uh you
can buy ads and put yourself on the TV
and become famous right and so I think
that um you know there there is this
kind of innate human orientation around
having more stuff and then we
rationalize why we have those things and
we rationalize All Humans rationalize
all their behavior in some like
alternative way like no one's innately
evil no one thinks I'm gonna do a bad
thing today everyone thinks they're
doing things for a good reason and so
what we do yeah good intention so we
have this kind of unconscious
orientation and I would call it kind of
almost programming I mean I don't know
you probably know Jeremy England yeah
oh he was yeah and um
I think like there's this idea that in
in
um in physics we're just oriented around
consuming more energy and then Nick Lane
I talked about his book on my podcast
uh where you know if you think about it
it's quite simple
um the feedback loop will dominate in a
kind of chaotic system the feedback loop
that can self-replicate yeah so the
self-replicating feedback loop wins and
so it absorbs all the energy and so on
anyway we're oriented that way and then
we rationalize our orientation our
desire for more stuff uh whether it's
fame or influence or money
um because we think we're doing a good
thing and then everyone's got their own
story on that and I could tell you my
story but someone else will
tell you another story around
what do I intend to do with my wealth
what do I intend to do with my fame what
do I intend to do with my influence why
do I want to be president I want to help
people why do I want to have all this
money I want to help people why do I um
you know want to have um all this Fame
because then I can help X Y or Z
everyone's got this kind of altruistic
intent that they rationalize this
orientation around how much of it is
ultimately realized or not is honestly
there's a lot of motivation and energy
that they put into it and luck is
associated with it on what they can
actually realize in terms of impacting
the world but like most people we want
to have an influence on the world we
want to see the things around us the
things that are not us the influenced by
us and
um and we use one of those three kind of
vectors of aggregation uh to to intend
to do that so you know I could I could
tell you a bunch of stories around
nonprofits I could tell you about my
interest in creativity and changing the
world finding problems solving problems
that's what I want to do with my wealth
move Humanity forward have less
suffering those are all the things I'm
super excited and interested by
um
and you know I think like my my again I
I try and be very honest about how much
of this is me rationalizing my role in
the universe like we always like we all
do right like I wanna like even
scientists I want to have a discovery
that can move the world forward that can
help us understand the universe better I
mean that was always my intention as a
kid my interest as a kid was like I want
to understand how the universe works
right and then I want everyone to know
that and then you know and that's my
fave right like if I if I look really
deeply as a kid I wanted to be famous
for being Einstein like I wanted to
discover stuff and then be famous and if
we all examine our innate kind of right
if we all examine this innately I think
that there is one of those three vectors
that we Orient ourselves around and then
we rationalize the altruistic intent of
it right we bet we backfill in the
narrative to uh support the the innate
desires that we have which I don't think
are bad I mean I talked to a very very
famous uh astrophysicist at Cornell Lisa
keltenegger uh recently on the podcast
and she uh she's the director of the
Carl Sagan Institute there I would be
focused on looking at approaches you
know we got to get you guys some some
besties eventually get you some bestie
finger puppets this is the greatest swag
they're awesome uh but I said you know I
said to her Lisa if you had a choice
between
um be finding slime mold on you know
some exoplanet Proxima Century B uh at
the end of your career or and then
getting a letter from God that says
there's no other form of life in the
universe especially technological
Advanced uh aliens
um and that would be what choice number
a letter a is you get to discover slime
mold and you're the first person in
history to ever Discover Life on another
exoplanet or B uh your great great great
great you know Grand PhD daughter she
discovers aliens you know with
extraterrestrial technology a thousand
years from now which would you choose
and she was like both and I'm like you
can't choose both you know but I get you
know it's the instant gratification that
goes to the fame and you know as famous
I think uh Bill Murray once said you
know if you if you want to be you know
famous try being rich first you know
because that gives you most of the
benefits of being uh of being famous
without any of The Unwanted benefits or
without many of The Unwanted benefits
um so I want to uh pivot from from well
to an audience question uh good friend
Kelly uh G from uh Brooklyn is a huge
fan of yours uh she wants to talk me to
ask you about super gut which you know I
got a glass of it here I actually have
Monique uh which I uh you know still has
such good shelf life that I can still
drink it even though it's been rebranded
as super good I believe is that right
yes called super gut now so she's better
better name easier yeah much better yeah
super anything with super in the name is
gonna be good um and then Grand unified
theory I'm glad that you put the gut in
there too because you know we we all
want a granular there you go uh so she
has she's wasted you know millions of
dollars on on probiotics
um and uh and she wants to ask about
prebiotics versus probiotics in the
microbiome what what about that what are
the opportunities there why did you
invest in this company as a case study
maybe for my for my listeners uh can you
talk walk us through our thought process
there
there's a ton of so
20 years ago the human genome
um
uh was fully sequenced and it was
published I think 2003 right 2002.
um and it cost like 100 million dollars
to sequence the human genome at that
time and took months or years to seek to
put all the sequences together yeah now
digital Technologies
have driven the cost down of DNA
sequencing faster than Moore's law in
the past 20 years
um and that's because DNA sequencers are
Optical scanners and so you're
generating gigabytes of data
transmitting that data storing it
Computing it all those underlying
digital technologies have dropped in
cost by substantially and so the cost of
DNA sequencing has gotten really low the
speed has gotten really high Etc as a
result we are able to see the physical
world the DNA in the physical world at a
resolution that was never possible
before much like telescopes or
observatories have allowed us to appear
farther back in time deeper into space
wider you know
um uh whiter kind of point of view than
we've ever had before we can do the same
by looking down into the physical world
and the physical world is just littered
with microorganisms with living biology
that does stuff and creates molecules
and consumes molecules and does stuff
all around them
um in the human gut there's about 40
trillion bacterial cells plus or minus a
lot of kind of controversy on how many
there are roughly 10 trillion human
cells in the body also a little bit of
controversy on that number but call it
you know roughly equivalent order of
magnitude number of cells of bacteria in
humans those bacterial cells are making
molecules and absorbing molecules and
then they're also interacting with and
regulating human cells in a really
powerful way and we never had the
ability to see these bacterial cells and
understand what they are and what
they're doing so in just the last couple
of years because the cost of DNA
sequencing has come down we can now peer
into the gut and see what bacterial
populations are there and what they're
doing and this is not just crew in the
human gut it's also true in agriculture
and soil so we can now see in the soil
all what microbes are maybe fixing
nitrogen from the atmosphere making it
available to plants and improving plant
health and productivity what microbes
are stimulating to the plant what
microbes are keeping bugs away
etc etc what microbes are bad
and so the cost of DNA sequencing now
you can get a sample done for five bucks
let's say and it used to cost five
thousand okay so now all of a sudden we
have this Insight with large data sets
and with large data sets we have the
ability to mine those data sets and
identify Trends and identify you know
what's going on and start to test and
prove things scientific method so the
number of papers on the gut biome has
kind of grown geometrically last couple
years
um and so it turns out that the human
gut microbiome which is all the microbes
that live in our gut are very
significant and important influences of
our of our health in our body and um
they are doing all sorts of things they
are absorbing molecules they're
consuming molecules they're converting
molecules and um they can also have a
profoundly negative effect on human
health there are certain microbes that
have proteins on their surface that look
like proteins of the human cells of
certain human cells and for certain
genetically inclined people your immune
system attacks those microbes in your
gut and as a result it makes antibodies
to those proteins that mimic microbes in
your body and that's called protein
mimicry and then it causes an autoimmune
reaction and you have autoimmune disease
or inflammation or what have you so
there's all these discoveries that are
being made in in multiple sclerosis in
um lupus and Sjogren's and like
um all these kind of autoimmune diseases
and then there's also all these benefits
that we're discovering that certain
types of microbes can prevent soundly
improve our sleep improve our mood that
there's this whole gut brain axis that
we can actually regulate dopamine and
serotonin and these important
neurochemicals by stimulating certain
right um the whole thing gut decision
let me you know go with your gut right I
mean that has wisdom yeah yeah gone so
we asked ourselves a couple years ago I
think it was 2017 or 2018 I was reading
all these papers and I was talking about
this guy in the space we're talking lots
of people that understood the gut
microbiome and what's going on and we
were like maybe let's do a personalized
probiotics business so we'll we'll take
your poop we'll measure it and we'll
give you personalized probiotics and you
know a bunch of things happen we realize
number one probiotics generally do not
inoculate the gut because the gut
microbiome is like a jungle there's all
these trees and you know the monkey
climbs the tree eats the nuts the monkey
poops the poop grows the tree the Jaguar
comes in and eats the monkey there's a
whole ecosystem going on some you know a
regulatory what's called if microbial
Consortium or Consortium
um that's kind of regulating one another
so if you throw a house cat in the
jungle the house cat's gonna get eaten
it's not going to survive you can't just
throw a single bug in the gut and expect
it to inoculate so paper after paper
after paper has demonstrated that that
probiotic that actually putting
microbial organisms even if they're
alive in your gut they don't stay there
they don't grow
one thing that did show up quite
significantly was you can actually
change the feedstock in your gut and
profoundly change that ecosystem as a
whole that's this Prebiotic term and one
of the big Prebiotic kind of Concepts
that people have done a lot of papers on
a lot of work on was resistant starch no
one had built a business selling
resistant starch you know in a easy
consumable way for consumers and when
you consume resistance starch it
increases these gram-positive bacteria
in your population and your gut they
secrete short chain fatty acids into
your bloodstream
short-term fatty acids drop your blood
sugar regulate insulin sensitivity all
these sorts of you know reduce
inflammation so I was like this is the
Better Business we don't need to do this
crazy poop testing thing like you know
let's so that's how we ended up starting
the super gut but it really is this kind
of we have another business in the soil
microbiome space where we actually
measure Farmer's soil and then we give
them a readout that isn't just giving
them all the Latin names and the
population counts they have no idea what
that is we translate that into a very
specific set of decisions that they
should make to drive better outcomes in
their Farm
um and that company is called pattern
act so you know that that's that's I
think all enabled by this print so you
know speaking to our Point earlier on we
kind of looked at that scientific trend
of what's going on with DNA sequencing
costs and all these discoveries that are
being made
separately we looked at the markets and
then we found the right teams to go and
execute against these business ideas
um so that's kind of the the connecting
the dot concept awesome great
um okay so the next thing uh that would
be really interesting to talk about is
again in the biology space and I want to
push back on some of the pushback maybe
that you got recently on all in for you
know your conversation about about Cove
at night I should just say Co mid 19 you
know just to confuse YouTube because I
had I had put it this way it's it's this
is just you know the world's smallest
violin will be used but I I did um I did
an episode with Charles seif as
professor at NYU and a big critic of of
uh of Berkeley labs nuclear fusion you
know claims and so forth we'll get to
that in a minute but uh we we did a
podcast about about that result and and
the and the um the laser Fusion last
last month announced by the doe Etc and
uh and it got slapped with a climate
warning and uh and uh you know and
application that we should consult with
with Wikipedia and the United Nations
about climate change and all we said was
you know if Fusion would work then it
could be as you pointed out two months
ago or so on the on the podcast you know
could be one of the vectors that we use
to decarbonize the atmosphere and
actually desalinate the oceans uh et
cetera it could have vast positive
impact but anyway I want to touch
another hot button third rail issue with
a superconducting room temperature
maglev train and that's gain of function
what's wrong with gain of function I I I
had covet over the summer
you know a bunch of kids running around
they all got caught my wife didn't get
it which was kind of interesting
um and she swears is because of this
rabbit's foot that she wears on her face
no she wears a mask like 24 7. uh it's
it's a thing uh but um yeah but again if
I I lost my my sense of taste and smell
and I and I I lost five pounds I dropped
five pounds David from my double chin to
my stomach no I'm just kidding I I lost
a couple pounds and and I thought well
this is great you know what if what if
like they did us a solid what if this
will be the new uh what are they uh
ozympic that Jason uh calcanus is so
infatuated with anyway what's wrong with
gain of function I mean could we use it
to benefit to do things like weight loss
and so forth
so uh gain of function I would say is
this kind of narrow view of a broader
um activity that goes on in um
protein engineering okay let's call it
that
um so and and it is a ubiquitous
Tool Set uh that is used in Labs
academic research and Commercial labs
around the world
uh to discover and create proteins
um that can kind of uh evolve our
species with their new Therapeutics and
and so on so so let me just kind of dig
into what goes on for a second
take a um
uh
like how is protein made we've talked
about this on on our podcast I'll just
just do a quick yeah uh five seconds on
this
dumb it down for theoretical cosmologist
please
yeah right okay so um you know proteins
are coated in genes
um in DNA and uh every uh three letters
of DNA
can be deemed a codon
um and there are you know call it 20
amino acids and you can kind of think
about a segment of DNA being a copy of
it kind of coming off as an RNA and that
RNA goes into a ribosome and every three
letters are selected and an amino acid
is printed and so you get this bead of
amino acids and that bead of amino acids
because of uh the uh kind of uh electric
potential of the different uh molecules
kind of collapses on itself and forms
this three-dimensional
complicated molecule called a protein
and that protein actually is a machine
it does stuff physically biophysically
it does stuff in the body yeah and it
can break molecules apart it can stick
molecules together it can carry
molecules around so all these different
proteins have different function it can
bind to stuff so the the right surface
on a protein can stick to say a cancer
cell or stick to say a sick cell or you
know do something interesting in the
body
so evolution
has driven the discovery and the
development of or sorry the development
of proteins
um that do all of these incredible
things in biology
um and
we now have the toolkit to create novel
proteins and use those to try and do new
things so we have created novel enzymes
that we use in laundry detergent that
are really good at breaking up dirt we
have created
um novel biologic drugs that can bind to
cancer cells and then the body's natural
immune system will come in and kill
those cancer cells we have created
um novel proteins
um that can replace dysfunctional
proteins in our body and and you know
have a profound benefit on people on
sick population the way that we kind of
design these proteins and the way that
we kind of explore what protein
mutations might do biophysically or what
protein mutations might allow us to do
is we change the DNA and we change the
DNA very rapidly either we mutate it or
we specifically edit the DNA because we
have tools to do that now where we can
edit DNA very specifically and we
express lots of different proteins and
then we assay them or measure them and
we see what they can do and that allows
us to do drug Discovery uh all this
other sort of stuff yeah and um Francis
Arnold won the um Nobel Prize a number
of years ago you may know her foreign
yeah and and you know her her directed
Evolution
um work is you know almost Mainstay now
in a lot of research labs around the
world for doing things like protein
Discovery and the exploration of where
proteins are going to go and what they
can do so the term gain a function is a
very narrow version of that which is how
do we evolve proteins or change proteins
to see how the proteins on a virus are
going to change what that virus does and
so it's about exploring the domain space
of the potential of a virus as it
evolves on its own because the little
DNA that makes up that virus or the RNA
that makes up that virus is going to
evolve on its own random mutations will
cause new viral proteins to emerge in
nature and then those new viral proteins
will the ones that are really good at
you know infecting their host and you
know persisting will end up dominating
evolutionarily and they will that you
know and that that DNA or that RNA will
start to persist and kind of become
dominant and so we have the toolkit to
kind of explore that ourselves without
waiting for nature to do it so it is a
good philosophical question on should we
do that and to what extent and what are
the limitations and how do we control
that but the fundamental toolkits to do
that are ubiquitous this work of
um uh you know evolutionary design is
ubiquitous it's used in many Labs from
industrial biotech Labs making enzymes
for laundry detergent all the way
through to biologics Labs all the way
through to you know viral academic
research Labs all over the world so the
idea that this was like a special crazy
one-off idea that these guys did this
gain of function research is like
totally missing the broader picture of
what goes on in biology today which is
that this is ubiquitous evolutionary
kind of protein exploration and so on
um and the particular application to
seeing where a virus is headed is a kind
of a narrow view of that
um and and I'm not gonna like I mean we
could debate the the merits and and
whatnot of doing that
merits and demerits is that the American
um of doing that work for for viral
Evolution and predicting viral evolution
um is there a benefit in doing so and
getting a ahead of the problem and
figuring out how we can stop the virus
from evolving or having a vaccine that's
ready for if the virus evolves maybe but
then you have a Brad Pitt 12 Monkeys
problem where maybe you create the
problem by doing that right and that's
what a lot of people are theorizing
happen with uh starts cov2 which is that
it was kind of a you know an
evolutionarily kind of designed virus
that got out of the lab and so you know
I don't know if you saw the movie 12
Monkeys but like you know you basically
like in Reverse time you're trying to
solve the problem and you create it in
the process
um
and so it's an important question can
you put guard rails around this can you
put barriers around this certainly it
makes sense to to say that yes you
should and yes you can and you know this
idea that the Wuhan lab in China um the
French who were supposed to be kind of
Partners in building this lab out came
along and said this lab is not uh it
should not be open they stepped out of
it there was a lot of warning signs and
you know should more action be taken
should we have a tighter set of
guardrails almost like we have the uh
the nuclear Regulatory Commission should
we have kind of a viral Regulatory
Commission right um and then uh have a
you know a much kind of tighter
framework for how we do this work
um but remember the Pandora's Box is
open I mean these tools are out there
and I think uh you know in a world where
these tools can be harnessed in an
offensive way we have to be thoughtful
about what's the right defensive
approach yeah yeah I saw Babylon B you
know story which is kind of like a
conservative version of The Onion it
said you know Pfizer announces new
vaccine effective against virus it
created in the lab but you know Jay
bhattachary was passed guest on the
podcast professor at Stanford MD PhD he
said you know gain a function is fine
more or less but you shouldn't be you
know on the on a base layer on a
platform that's a human pathogenic you
know as susceptible to human
pathogenesis so I think that's an
interesting you know division line
um so I want to check David you still
good on time because uh I've left yeah
going okay great so uh you mentioned you
mentioned you know the proteins and how
they evolve and how they react and what
they do now recently we've had things
with uh you know Alpha fold and and um
you know all sorts of breakthroughs
involving Ai and and that can do such
incredible things uh of course a big
thing that you have talked about a lot
is is GPT and artificial intelligence I
want to ask you you know based on your
physics you know perspective do you
remember from uh from undergraduate or
you know your encounters with Alex uh
our friend Alex villopenko what Einstein
uh called the happiest thought of his
life do you know what that do you
remember what that I I don't know the
answer now yeah it was that then
observer in free fall would experience
no gravitational force
um he called that the happiest thought
of his life and I hear all the stuff
from from friend and pass gas Max
tagmark and MIT that we're going to have
a i a e we're gonna have artificial
Einsteins and so forth but I'm always
you know kind of not very sanguine about
that because you know you look at that
statement by Einstein there's a lot
packed in there but two things in there
are you know he felt happy you know he
actually enjoyed the sensation of of
having this new knowledge for the first
time that the sensation of Free Fall
Would experience the result and that
experience would be no gravitational
force and that led to Einstein
equivalence principle which underpins
all of gr but the question is you know
to what extent is that replicable in a
human both the happiest thought and a
visceral Sensation that we as scientists
do get Guided by our senses
um you know so in other words can we can
we expect that we would have of a happy
thought thinking computer or a computer
that could visualize Free Fall is that
or is that just completely beyond what
we can do and that effectively what
these computers are doing is just a
level of computation that no human can
match but the creativity that you
mentioned earlier is never going to be
there
I'm not convinced about this notion of
um creativity per se
um
I I always Point people to this video by
this guy who calls himself an
Illusionist his name's Darren Brown out
of the UK oh yeah yeah and
um it's on YouTube and there's an
episode where or a clip of this episode
that he did years ago uh where he took
these Ad Agency Executives these guys
are like creative directors they make
ads and they're like the best in the
industry and they're super creative and
they come up with all these great ideas
and he goes and Picks Them Up puts them
in a cab takes them into his office and
in his office he's got a whiteboard and
then he's got another whiteboard covered
in a curtain and he says guys you I need
you to create like an ad for me come up
with the name for a pet cemetery company
come up with a logo come up with a
catchphrase and they spend all day the
cameras capture them ideating and going
back and forth and like theorizing and
like exploring all the domains of their
creativity and they finally settle on
this great concept of a logo and a name
and a couch phrase and then he comes
back hours later and he flips up the
curtain and he had it identically
correct and the way he did it is on the
cab ride over and I don't know how real
this all is but it really spoke to me on
the cab ride over
he kind of had these kids walk in front
of the cab with this t-shirt that had
this logo on it he had them drive past
the sign he repeated the same word over
and over on the buildings like and so
there was this like subliminal
programming that happened where by the
time they got to the building they were
unconsciously deeply influenced by this
image this name and this catchphrase and
they kind of felt like they were
discovering that through creative
process I think like this there is this
notion of like the human mind having to
some degree
um you know uh I mean we'll use like a
Jewish term of like Chabad which is like
knowledge understanding and wisdom right
we absorb this data We Gather this
knowledge we synthesize it together and
then we have this kind of Outlook and
you know there's these these uh sleep
and dream theorists or scientists that
say it's the synthesis the output that
ends up being stored in your brain not
the actual data uh and that's
effectively the neural model right
that's the neural network so to some
degree humans are programmable and we
are programmed and we are programmed to
have these kind of synthetic outputs
from the inputs that we receive and so
on what I think is missing from AI that
I never really have had anyone explain
well to me uh in terms of AGI uh you
know artificial general intelligence is
the association of the training data set
being the limbic system of the human
body right the Reno you've spent they
talk about sorry to interrupt but they
talk about reinforcement learning yeah
but they never mentioned that
reinforcement is coming from some human
you know Overlook overlords right
no that's right and and and what the
training data by the way just to be
clear like if you watch a baby we have
kids you have uh you know uh I'd say we
because you I know you have kids and you
watch your baby the baby first starts
interacting because there's a physical
visceral reaction there's a limbic
emotional reaction through their
physical body to some stimulus from the
outside and then we kind of build these
much more kind of complicated thoughts
and complicated networks but it's all
still driven by the the physical limbic
system by the reaction to the exterior
that we physically interact with that's
right that training data ultimately
realizes as these kind of Concepts and
then we have conceptual training but
that's often the output of like these
core engines and I think like so many of
these data sets that I you know that we
use as training data are often the
actual outputs and then we train on the
output so we don't train on the actual
human input what is the right kind of
human um data set to train on so if I
could wrap a human uh an MRI around a
human brain from the point of
development through to the point of
being an adult and I could
um you know capture all the things that
I believe that that Computing by the way
and digital Technologies allow us to
capture all the things that the human
body captured we just don't have the
response mechanism as data today to
train against that and so I can capture
feeling I can capture temperature I can
capture light I can capture smell I can
capture molecules all these things I can
capture as an input to my uh my model
what I'm not capturing is the training
data on what happens right yeah so it
makes me say ow that birth you know
right they always say oh and by the way
yeah
yeah like why does the baby run out and
move out of the way when someone comes
running at them so
um you know the the the the the the AI
can be trained on there's a body coming
at me but the association of I can get
hit and that will hurt is missing right
and I think that's the under the
underlying that that's kind of lacking
is that training data how do we get that
training does that ever actually resolve
and does that actually build models
um there's going to be a lot of stuff
that AI is going to be incredible at and
and like this whole synthesis of
creative process and creative thought
all the higher level abstraction stuff
it it's just data processing and the AI
will beat us at that yeah there's
something however that's missing in
terms of AGI that is deeply associated
with the human physical self and um I I
don't know I'm not convinced yeah they
used to say on Twitter you know you
weren't I'm also I should also say I'm
very naive on this stuff so yeah yeah as
am I I mean I just like to be you know
put on my pundit hat but you know I used
to say on Twitter it used to be
forbidden to say learn to code but now
journalists are just going to learn to
prompt and uh and furthermore or when
you talk about these training sets
they'll say like this AI solved this
this problem that would take humans 100
millionaire or whatever 10 years to
solve and I'm like well but did you
include the 10 years of 10 phds that it
took to come up with the level of input
programming that was used to make this
model and then you know my last kind of
thought on this subject before we turned
to just a side application of AI which I
am more single about but uh the the
notion that
um you know that that a computer can
beat a human a chess or go or protein
folding or whatever is well known but my
question is that you know can a computer
create the game of chess can a computer
create the game of Go or you know in
that same way can the computer create
you know Einstein tensors and and the
Einstein field equations I I'm not I'm
not convinced but I I am sanguine about
one thing but I'm I'm also kind of
anti-sanguine we we use um at nurse
which is a national Energy Research
supercomputer up there at Berkeley uh
Kali close colleague Julian Burrell is
one of the directors we use it for all
the cosmology data sets it's kind of
input processing they have the world's
you know third lar fastest computer
which tomorrow will be the 18th fastest
computer
um all sorts of really amazing
processors up there
and it's a facility for the government
but we get to use it on energy you know
sub slice but we found that actually a
lot of computing things are getting
slower because uh even though the raw
horsepower is increasing as Moore's law
but the the problem is that the demand
is also increasing faster than Moore's
Law at some level because these things
become so uh both both you know
attractive for researchers to use and so
much more powerful they can solve more
problems so it's this positive feedback
cycle in a way but the actual raw like
if you just translate it to what we
academics care about paper citations H
Industries whatever those are kind of
saturating based on even given that
these computers are improving and I
start to think about why that is and and
maybe in the in the health space I had
on Eric topal a year or two ago and he's
a big proponent of you know we got to
get computers out of the of the patient
doctor interaction because you just have
like a doctor looking at a screen and a
patient looking at another screen
um but I'm A Private Pilot I fly little
tiny Cessnas around Southern California
and it's not really well known but every
time I take off I have to listen to this
like FM radio station for about a minute
and every time I come in for a landing I
also have the list called the no Tam
system notice it used to be called
notice to air men people to judge and
others change that to notice to air
missions recently and that was famously
in the news it shut down for a couple
hours in January and that led to snarls
in the Aviation Administration but that
thing you actually have to listen to on
a radio on analog radio in the cockpit
and you have to tune in the radio with a
dial or type into a keypad and I'm like
why don't I have this Alexa you know
device or something you know I have one
in my in my room right now I I have a
different word than Alexa so I won't
trigger but I'm probably triggering
millions of people around the world
listening to this
um but you know I should have a virtual
co-pilot right the number one
contributor to safety of the Airlines
versus General Pilots like me is that
there's always two pile every plane
you've ever flown on David has two
pilots in it unless you've been the
pilot right so but why not augment for
both professional Pilots commercial
pilots and private Pilots like me I have
a little assistant in the cockpit that
knows O'Brien's coming up on Oakland
airport he's probably gonna land there
you know he put in his flight plan which
I have on a computer he should I should
really dial in the no Tams and listen to
it for him decode it visually which we
can read you know 10 times faster than
than listening um uh or writing so why
don't we have those things and it came
up as well in the medical you know why
isn't there an AI Alexa in the in the
room listening to Dr topal you know
prescribe whatever Vicodin I don't know
what he does but I should really check
in on him but uh but the point is why
don't we have that and I think it comes
down to lawyers I I think like the the
aviations you know there's hundreds of
lives on every commercial airliner what
do you think is the impediment why
aren't we actually scaling out so these
things are actually useful so I have a
virtual lab assistant or you know
virtual uh co-pilot or virtual
physician's assistant what's the
impediment is it you know legality and
if so
should we be hopeful that's going to
improve well with passage of time
yeah look I mean these are I I mean I
told people if you I think about
next evolution of software AI is just
the current catchphrite there have been
these catchphrases over the years of
data science and Big Data you know
machine learning algorithms and yeah
machine learning like there's always
some hypey that goes on and
sorry yeah no no bad words allowed show
um so so a lot of people are kind of you
thinking but at the end of the day it's
all about tools are about providing
leverage to Human so um there's an
evolution of a of a tool set that gives
us more leverage and I give people the
analogy like uh uh people that used to
make
um visual images were painters than
there were photographers and then there
were was Adobe Photoshop an Adobe
Photoshop would kind of digitize and
pixelate images and you would kind of
change the pixels
but then there was this higher order
tool set called Kai's power tools uh
developed by A team out of another UC
team out of UC Santa Barbara I believe
they were UC I know they were based in
Santa Barbara and um
and Kai's power tools was this plug-in
for Photoshop it was a set of plugins
and what it was you know a Photoshop an
image is just a matrix yeah and then it
would do some transformation on that
Matrix and generate a new Matrix and you
know the the statistics uh were coded
into software and those statistics were
used the statistical formula I were used
to transform the Matrix and now you have
what looks like a motion blur or a
gaussian blur or um you know a
pixelation effect or a sharpening effect
or a softening effect so there was all
these Kai's power tools effects special
effects you could add to your photo and
prior to this uh an Adobe Photoshop
photo editor would have to go in and
manually change the pixels and kind of
use a bunch of these you know Adobe
Photoshop tools to make those changes so
Photoshop totally transformed The
Leverage potential enabled by Photoshop
now the best users of Kai's power tools
weren't necessarily the best
photographers or even the best pixelated
pixel editors it was the person who had
the best ideas of how to use the tool
cool and the tools now you could do all
this other cool stuff and we could
extend ourselves into doing higher order
stuff
um and so I think you know we've seen
software introduced that allowed us to
do things like autopilot and flying
um and now autopilot in driving yeah and
um you know it's it's not necessarily
fully self-driving but it's not you have
to do as much driving anymore it's
providing you more leverage
um and I think that it's not about kind
of on or off all of these tools are
going to integrate into our everyday
life uh commercial markets Capital
markets will drive interest you as a
pilot will be willing to pay for that AI
driven kind of capability it will find
its way into your cockpit because you do
have a regulatory problem with flying
and with driving and so on so some of
these things take a little bit longer to
get approved than stuff that could just
make its way in the market like a new
software editor or photo editor and so
on
um but I think that's my general kind of
orientation around what AI is it's a
series of uh you know software and and
statistics and algorithms enabled in
software provide us this kind of ever
extending
um leverage uh with our time and with
our
um abilities as a human and we always
end up leveling up right and we're going
to level up going forward I tell people
we're kind of entering the narrator
economy where we no longer need creators
people that create stuff the software
will create the the script the music the
movie the the visuals and I as a
narrator will simply tell the software
you know pan left to right go up 30
degrees change the character make her a
little angrier right now uh give her a
Brooklyn accent I mean I will now be
directing my computer to make a movie
for me that provides me leverage and it
also enables more people to become
um
um uh directors of movies uh you know
there's only probably 50 people that
direct a movie or 150 or probably 5 000
people a year that'll direct the movie
now there can be five million and the
software will render the movie for you
and prior you know there were only maybe
5 000 people that could uh edit photos
and now there's five million people that
are editing photos using this toolkit
daily or using 5 billion or a billion
people that are using Google photos and
apple photos to edit their photos every
day now yeah um and so you know you when
humans level up through kind of the
evolution of software and current
iteration it's AI
um not only does it provide us kind of
more leverage but it also provides more
access and more people and and then we
all kind of transform our lifestyles so
I don't know that's my that's why we're
interested around this and yeah
everything will unfortunately eventually
devolve to pornography right so that's
been you know the history of Technology
from TV to VHS DVDs and then the
internet and now unfortunately they're
going to be making movies David I think
you're right but I think it's going to
be personalized in a and a
non-non-kosher direction shall we say
Okay quick question from a uh an
audience member just a reminder you can
always submit questions to me and guess
when I post them on Twitter uh Dr Brian
Keating uh YouTube Dr Brian Keating as
well uh rarely on Instagram but uh we're
talking today with uh David Friedberg
who's a renowned thinker investor
prolific
um kind of curious person who I see you
as a ponderer if I'd like to say I see
you as an optimistic pessimist or
pessimistic Optimist and it's really a
delight to speak with you uh and you can
uh of course uh follow him wherever
podcasts are sold and bought and on
Twitter at Friedberg as well or he's uh
sometimes active now the uh the next
question comes as I say from uh from one
of my listeners and he asks is there a
possibility in your life In Our Lifetime
that aging could be suspended that comes
from Reynold cherry
yeah so
um we have to so how do we measure aging
and what are the drivers of Aging
um you know uh
the The genome
uh codes all the the proteins that
biology makes uh the Genome of a species
or an organism
and um there's long been this kind of
set of theories that mutations in the
genome over time
um you know entropy kind of drives the
genome to to kind of or disorientation
and as a result it stops producing the
right proteins and cells become
dysfunctional and eventually they stop
working right and then you get things
like cancer maybe Alzheimer's uh or they
just stop working altogether you go
blind and you die I mean you know
um the dysfunction of uh gene expression
um the wrong proteins expressed at the
wrong time really is kind of seems to be
the core driver of Aging um now we
thought historically maybe this was
driven by mutations in the DNA uh in
cells that accumulate over time and
increasingly there's evidence as
published a few weeks ago in two
different papers
um uh including one out of uh um led by
a team out of Harvard
that um it may be dysfunction it's not
in the genome in the DNA but actually
dysfunctions in the epigenome which is
the molecules that sit on the DNA and um
certain molecules allow the DNA to be
more openly expressed because it opens
up the nucleosomes has more space and
then uh the RNA copies come out more
proliferately and then more copies of
that Gene are expressed and in some
cases it blocks the genome and and turns
off or shuts off certain genes and um
that as these molecules kind of get
ripped off and some get put on in the
wrong way we're seeing dysfunctional
gene expression in a Cell which causes
the wrong proteins to be made and the
right proteins are missing and then the
cell as a whole stops working the cell
gets inflamed eventually it dies all
this sort of bad stuff starts to happen
and that that may be at this point the
likely driver of Aging
so it's an accumulation of errors in the
epigenome in cells throughout the body
now the exciting science
um is what we talked about earlier which
is the set of yamanaka factors these
four molecules that have these
transcription factors that have been
proven
to go in and help reset the epigenome
and if you apply enough of the yamanaka
factors into a cell the epigenome resets
in a way that that whole cell starts
acting like a stem cell it can
differentiate into any other cell in the
body it was when it was a primary
primitive version of itself
right and and it turns out that you can
actually partially reprogram a cell
which means you just make you reset the
epigenome so that that cell starts to
work like it's supposed to work like for
that whether you know there's about 200
different cell types in the human body
so whether it's a brain cell or an eye
cell or a skin cell or a heart cell uh
muscle cell
um you can kind of apply a small amount
of those transcription factors to that
cell and actually get it to act in a
younger way and this was demonstrated in
improving the lifespan of mice by
applying this um uh this this the first
they disrupted the epigenome and they
applied these yamanaka factors to the
mice and then the mice became Young And
They Live Twice As long and they were
healthier and everything was better
their cognitive functioning went up
heart rates went up you know all the
good Hearts started working better et
cetera
um so that's a great you know let's go
back to Pure science like that's where
we are we have this kind of pure
scientific like trajectory where this
takes us what's the scrum on the Rugby
field to use the analogy once again on
what this is going to look like from a
therapeutic perspective from a business
model perspective and how long will it
take us to get down the field totally
TBD there are all these ideas that we
can take for example eye cells and
rejuvenate them and then put them back
in and the eyes will work better that we
can maybe
um take certain immune cells out of our
blood rejuvenate them put them back in
and the immune cell starts functioning
better
um that maybe this can be used to
regulate um uh um neurons and get the
brain to work a little bit better so you
know how do you deliver the right
transcription factors and then there's
all this research by the way that maybe
it's not just those four transcription
factors that were demonstrated at that
won the Nobel Prize by yamanaka but
maybe there's thousands of other
transcription factors and maybe there's
human engineered transcription factors
and then how do we get those
transcription factors in the right dose
into the right cell at the right time so
that's all the work that's going to be
going on for I don't I can't possibly
predict for how long you know there will
be inklings of advances along the way
certain businesses someone will come up
with some therapeutic where maybe
they'll do something to some cell in the
body and it'll work and they'll get it
productized and you know
um but yes I do think that this idea
that um you know cells
um uh the human body as a whole which is
um kind of a it's such a dynamic
biochemical bag like you know can we
control the entropy in that bag
um it turns out that there may be some
keys to doing that um and that's super
exciting science so you mentioned and
that yes I do think like yeah we I do
think we can see persistence in the
human form for a lot longer than we have
today
um into the hundreds of years
theoretically I mean you could theorize
any answer to that yeah you could say
yes certainly keep the human alive
forever yeah
if it's falsified and it doesn't occur
in your lifetime you're dead so it
doesn't matter to you
um you mentioned rugby a couple times
and one of my good friends as an
engineer he's from South Africa loves
the spring backs or whatever they're
called uh it's Gabby Gavin here in San
Diego and uh I think he'd be curious to
know
um you uh your parents are from South
Africa
um were you born there or I
were you born inside that yeah I was
born there I I moved from Cape Town when
I was six years old L.A so you can't be
president uh unfortunately of America
cannot be president uh but um why did
why did your parents leave and what
would there be any sort of uh you know
thing that would bring you back we have
a lot of uh South Africans here in San
Diego it's a huge part of our community
here
um I I think rumored to live here in La
Jolla and San Diego because of the
weather and the climate and the
topography it's just like Cape Town yeah
but why did they leave and uh and would
you ever could you ever see a scenario
where you would go back permanently or
temporarily sabbatical or something like
that
no I mean apartheid uh was ending in the
early to mid 80s it was evident that it
was going to end and the country was
going to change over quite a bit which
meant that there was a lot of kind of
geopolitical risk and uncertainty about
the economic and physical climate and so
that's when a lot of people left so we
left and my parents most of my family
moved to London on both sides of my
family and then um my parents are
documentary filmmakers they wanted to go
in La so we went to LA
and they worked in um I I've yeah
there's nothing that motivates me to go
to South Africa except to visit and take
my kids and show them and check it out
and hang out Cape Town so I do remember
Cape Town being beautiful I went back
once since I left
um but uh yeah there's there's no reason
I would kind of go back there like
obviously so much of my work and friends
and family are all here at this point
absolutely
um there is you know obviously a lot of
scientific
um collaborations that flourish we have
collaborators there in South Africa UCT
and other places so shout out to them my
friend Amanda development Professor down
there
um next up uh I am the associate
director of the Arthur C Clark Center
for human imagination here at UC San
Diego and I'm always interested you know
Sir Arthur was uh very very of course
conversant with uh with uh science fact
and as you know purportedly responsible
for you know Concepts Like geostationary
Satellites although you know some people
debate that but um but nevertheless he
pre-saged many things and and uh in his
in his Works including things like the
iPad and and uh you know permanent uh
habituation on the space station uh
science fiction no play any role in your
in your life have you uh are you uh part
attracted to any particular science
fiction authors and if so do you think
science fiction has a role to play in
science nonfiction in other words as a
way to kind of pregame or or kind of
thought think out things uh for for
science actual in practice
yeah look I mean I think one of the
um
extraordinarily important role of
Science Fiction plays is thinking in
first principles take away where we are
today and the comparatives and the
comparables of the world today and try
and extend everyone tries to extend
those comparatives and those comparables
strip it all away and just say what do
the first principles of X tell me and
what's possible based on those first
principles and based on that I can
nibly different universe and then I can
think about all the paths that get us
from here to there and you know um
I'll give one example and then I'll talk
about Arthur C Clarke um Star Trek the
Next Generation my favorite show of all
time right and you know like the
universe is just matter and energy and
if we can kind of harness energy to uh
reorient matter uh I mean so much of
what goes on in biology in in humans
moving our physical bodies around it's
like it's it's so crazy because it's
just like moving molecules from one
place to another and then we kind of
absorb this information
um in the form of photons and uh and
those photons ultimately resolve some
biochemical change in our neural network
which is a bunch of molecules and so
those photons are just influencing the
physical structure of our of our
molecules in our what we call our body
which by the way our body will be a
whole different set of molecules in a
couple years anyway right um if you're
tracking a molecule all the way through
it's kind of Lifetime um
so uh yeah I think um Star Trek the Next
Generation did a great job one of the
things about Star Trek the Next
Generation I always appreciated was the
um the replicator this idea that like if
we can actually fully harness energy and
just reorient molecules locally instead
of running through all these physical
you know humans started with mechanical
engineering uh you know and then we did
like chemical engineering and now we do
biochemical engineering which is
actually changing these really complex
biomolecules to do more machine chemical
manipulations for us yeah Machining
molecules for us
um
and you know there's elements of physics
where we're kind of doing interesting
manipulation now on an atomic scale
right Atomic layer deposition I it could
be called chemical engineering but it
may be a little different
um
so much of of that I think paints a
picture that this trajectory maybe is
reasonable which is that in the future
we can kind of take carbon hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen and maybe a few other
kind of heavier elements and just
reorient them locally using some set of
Technologies to instantaneously make the
things we want and that the only cost is
energy and then if the cost of energy is
free well holy now humans live in
this extraordinarily abundant universe
and we can make anything we want and you
know and go nuts and live our kind of
abundant Lifestyles
um Star Trek had all these really great
theories around what happens in that
world which is like the economy
collapses does society collapse turns
out in Star Trek it doesn't I'm not sure
if that would really happen here yeah um
but I do think my orientation and my
level of interest in the work I do is
how do we get to a point where the
economy does go to zero where the cost
of everything does go to zero where
every human can have everything they
want because the technology is
sufficiently Advanced that we can kind
of just reorient molecules locally using
you know infinitely abundant energy to
have the physical experiences we want
all the time and give ourselves kind of
extraordinary like Adventure and
exploration potential and so on that
that's that's I think the right kind of
north star or you know human
civilization kind of social engineering
uh you know our long-term outcome now
that brings me to Arthur C Clarke
and in 2001
um there was a treatment written by
Arthur C Clarke before the script and
then the book was written after the
script I don't know if you've ever read
the treatment The Sentinel or something
right
no The Sentinel was an old Story the
treatment for the movie uh I'll send it
to you I've got some copies of it um but
it came in the art it came in that there
was a Tasha book series on on a 2008 and
2001 and they actually included it in
Natasha book series I've got it it's an
incredible read oh yeah because he
highlights how like at the beginning
uh if you think about a sufficiently
advanced civilization this is also leads
into my point of view on like
extraterrestrials and UFOs and and so on
which I think are very naive human
thoughts
um because a sufficiently advanced
civilization looks a lot more like what
I just described which is the ability to
harness energy to make any molecule into
anything locally and then the universe
is simply about information transmistal
transmittal so transmission so the
transmission of photons to
um from one point to another provides
you everything you need to accumulate
more knowledge and more understanding of
the universe and maybe gravitational
waves too or whatever whatever other
kind of insights we can gather from the
universe
but every everything from you and I
staring at a screen today is photons
flowing into our eyes DNA sequencers are
photons being scanned on an optical
scanner a lot of the work you do in
cosmology or the the um you know the
experimental physics is is some sort of
sensor Gathering of photons
so if the universe if ultimately the
universe is just about photons providing
information about where and what other
molecules in the universe are doing and
we can sufficiently gather those photons
and then we sufficiently can move
molecules around using energy to make
anything we want locally what is the
purpose of interstellar travel right it
it suddenly it suddenly doesn't make
sense why would I take my physical body
to go to another planet if I could
gather the information from that planet
and recreate and take whatever I need
from that planet make it locally also
humans ability to kind of do things like
you know um uh kind of transmutation of
elements like if I could make heavy
elements I don't need to go mine at the
elements from an asteroid or something I
can just use energy can do that for me
as you know so if I can capture enough
energy I can manipulate molecules any
way I want and I can gather the photons
from around the universe to figure out
what's going on I don't need to go
anywhere uh as a an intelligent species
um and so that was the premise defined
and described better than I just did in
the treatment that Arthur C Clarke wrote
for 2001 which is the universe is the
Galaxy is just like a network with a
bunch of nodes on it and those nodes
were the monoliths and they were
transmitting and accumulating
information because you don't need to
have a physical body go out there to
transmit and gather information and you
don't need to physically gather
molecules anymore because you have the
technical ability to do that all locally
and then the the the
um
you know the the the transmission and
collection of information is the role of
intelligent species at that point
um and and you don't need to kind of
move around and do stuff so it kind of
in in a sufficiently advanced
civilization you don't need to move
things around with UFOs and and you know
so on and so forth
um so that was a really kind of uh
profound thought and then I think that
there's another really important
profound thought which is that species
at some point realizes my individual
interest as an information gathering
entity or body you kind of get at some
point a little bit selfless
sufficiently Advanced and you realize
that it is the aggregation of bodies of
the aggregation of molecules perhaps
that are the craters and absorbers and
transmitters of information and it is
not the individual body itself
um
like there's a book called parasite Rex
which talks about microbes and parasites
that infect organisms and then control
those organisms and that you know we
talked a little bit about the gut biome
earlier but humans mood and behavior is
so dramatically driven by their gut
microbiome yeah there's tens of
trillions of organisms are we
controlling our body or the organisms
controlling our body if the words I'm
saying and the feelings I'm having are
driven by some set of organisms in my
uh or you know there's some really good
examples of like a a bacteria that
affects an ant and then the ant gets
eaten by a sheep the ant when it gets
infected the ant climbs to the top of a
blade of grass the Sheep eats the blade
of grass so the ant goes in the sheep's
gut and then the bacteria proliferates
in that gut gets pooped out again and
infects the next ant and that's the way
that this gut bacteria drives itself
um is it it actually forces ants to go
crazy and climb up the blade of grass
and that's where they get eaten and just
there's a research by a friend we
mentioned her earlier in the context of
covid but this is a Kim pray there's a
chemistry National Academy I think of
Science and Engineering she has this um
um you know done research in the role
that microbes play in the atmospheric
Rivers phenomenon of you know that we
just experienced recently in California
so so that's where microbes are somehow
seeding and providing you know seeds and
nucleation sites for droplets which then
proliferate and cause these huge deluges
which then causes uh the curing of
droughts which had stressed the
microbial Colony so there in other words
that microbes are not only affecting you
know us and maybe more than us as you
know Ed young wrote and I contain
multitudes and everything you know as
you said earlier we're more microbes
than human whatever that means but they
may actually be geoengineering the
planet which is really remarkable how do
they know how to do this but anyway
sorry to interrupt but continue well no
I mean that's that's my point I think
humans have a very human-centric point
if you are the universe yeah like you
know we
yeah we it is it really is like I think
that there is this point in
intelligent design where the
intelligence recognizes that it is not
the center it is not you know that that
this fungus this fungusome is bacteria
that are actively changing everything on
this planet and maybe we're just a
byproduct of the work that that they're
doing in a non-intelligent way and the
aggregation of all this biomass and the
effect it's having on the planet
um you know is kind of the the center of
what's going on here and again step out
it's predicted Maybe by thermodynamics
and maybe there's an uh a system of
what's the better kind of energy
absorber and dissipator uh that uh
that's kind of driving all that change
um in this particular system
um so so so I think that there then you
reach this evolutionary point where
maybe civilization or intelligence
realizes it's not
it's not the thing and that's the thing
maybe is kind of the bigger picture
right um it maybe it is the the bigger
system that that these molecules are all
a part of yeah um I often say and and
then I think the the most likely thing
that ends up happening is stuff that we
have absolutely no concept of today that
really is the Transcendence of
intelligence that that we just can't see
today right so yeah speaking about you
know people who say oh you know I want
to live forever actually I see two
different camps people that don't want
to live forever and people that do want
to live forever but people that want to
live forever
um I say it's possible to do that right
now uh it just won't be you and your
physical body it'll either be in some
Avatar of you or you know try having
children or biological or ideological
and we'll get to that when we hit my
existential question
um you know format at the end of this
episode
um coming up but but the point being you
know people are kind of greedy they want
to take their body and their house and
their and their jet ski you know and
live forever with it but uh but really
you can sustain things with your values
or you know you could have some Avatar
right that in cap capsulates and codes
every every state of your mind if you're
a materialist but then that begs a
question for you David are they already
here in other words I agree with you
it's much more of um you know kind of
prudent for advanced intelligence to to
be here but in the Avatar former
artificial form and and not their
physical form you know swapping you know
sending their DNA or q a or whatever
they have uh here to Earth uh but why
wouldn't that kind of presuppose as you
know recently canceled uh former past
guest on the podcast Nick Bostrom has
suggested you know the super
intelligence that will proliferate and
we almost have to have the burden to
falsify that such an intelligence isn't
already here you know creating us in a
simulation so as you know in all
podcasts have to talk about aliens
Bitcoin and simulation hypothesis at
least in the science room what do you
think about that could could we actually
be visited by extraterrestrial
intelligences but in the form of
something digital it's traveling at the
speed of light collecting information
from Sentinels and Monument throughout
the Galaxy
um
I mean I I would say that humans are
probably more programmed by the
collective internet than we are
individually programming the collective
internet ourselves today the internet so
ever like some meta intelligence or the
actual internet
look I mean you could take a people or a
set
you could kind of
take your human hat off for a second
there's some
um there's some way to draw a circle
around things and I I would say like if
you take the uh all these Computing
resources that are connected together
just that call that the internet
and then the output is a bunch of
photons and maybe the movement of
speakers to make sound
um the what's coming out of that
Collective system into your body if
is probably affecting your emotional
conditioning a lot more then you're
changing the way that that Collective
internet thing is operating many people
stare at their phones all day
and they're browsing and scrolling and
photons are just being pushed into their
eyes and sounds being pushed into their
ears and as they're browsing and
scrolling they're having dopamine
reactions they're having emotional
reactions they're going to change their
behavior they're quote learning things
they're going to quote do things uh this
little device that you're holding is
programming you and it's telling you
what to feel and what to do all day long
um now the first principle is basis so I
I I don't know if there's this idea of
like some higher dimensional order of
simulation needed as much as the simple
observation
that you know we as humans and our
concept of kind of centralized
Intelligence being like the human body
and that's it versus recognizing that
there is kind of a collective
experience or a collective intelligence
that is perhaps where the edge of the
node or the edge of the network now and
we're being kind of pushed stuff to to
feel and say and do uh you know we sit
in front of our TVs we uh in our iPhones
we're told a bunch of stuff the way we
as humans interpret what's going on is
there are other humans in that machine
and they know stuff and they're telling
me stuff you and I are talking to each
other through a computer right now but
really the reality is I'm sitting in a
freaking room staring at a piece of
electronics
using my mouth to talk to it and
changing how I am behaving because of
how this piece of electronics is is kind
of flooding me with photons and sound
and so um
I do think that that we need to kind of
just have this higher order point of
view absent the the human brain um
intelligence concept uh that there is a
collective thing going on um I'm just
like all about like let's just not be
human-centric when we think about things
and you very quickly kind of have a
different point of view on the world in
the universe we're talking about uh
human to human how these little black
mirrors are changing our lives uh some
ways for the better some ways is a
challenge uh so you're a father I'm a
father
um I've had the experience I don't know
if you've had this yet with your kids
but you know when I'm talking to one of
them they'll try to swipe you know my
face to change the channel so to speak
or change this they're so used to
interacting with things they can swipe
um what what how do you react to
technology and with your children and um
and you know what what do you see as
sort of uh you know practical ways do
you put limits on uh on this or you know
how do you handle this
whatever I say is going to be wrong I
mean like so I mean we all I think all
parents are so critical of their the
limits that they allow their kid to kind
of have with technology I mean I see my
kids watching junk shows I turn it off I
limit the stuff they're allowed to show
we try and do 30 minute Max on iPad or
something like that but it's it's brutal
to see how quickly captivated you are
but then I think back to my childhood I
mean I was on freaking cable TV for six
hours as a 10 year old watching shows in
front of the TV for hours on end I don't
know I think I felt was able to function
later and was still able to have kind of
learning capacity later so I can't be
too judgmental
um
you know I I recently got my kids
playing uh PS5 like there's this game
that comes with the PS5 called Astros
playroom
um and my kids saw me playing and they
wanted to play and so I taught them how
to play and it's incredible how quickly
they learned and how good they got at it
how fast they got at it and I'm like
holy like this is actually really
cool seeing them advance and then
they're thinking really critically and
like physically like like what what's
the the spatially I think is the answer
um is the word
um thinking like uh spatially like where
do I go and how quickly and how and we
started doing races on it and they got
better and better and then they started
like uh really thinking about it as a
puzzle and I'm watching them actually
puzzle solve and respond quickly to
stuff and I was like this isn't bad I
started reading some stuff on video
games at an early age and like a lot of
kids that are engineers and software
engineers and did really well like you
learn critical thinking through some of
um uh that experience that so you know I
think those sort of things are kind of
actually cool I try and limit how much
we do we usually do like 30 minutes
after dinner and then we're done yeah
um but it's hard man I there's there's
like there's no black and white I'm not
like a ball technology it's bad guy I
also hate them watching these shows
where it's like cheeky people I I care
more about the values than I do about
um them just watching shows if there's a
show where the kids are like being mean
or there's violence or there's
cheekiness that's the stuff I don't want
to have around because that's not the
values I want them to learn
um if it's playing video games and doing
puzzle strategy stuff I'm fine with it
up to a limit like with everything it's
got to be up to a limit
um so yeah that's that's just my
orientation I think just making sure
that there's always the layer of values
and the translation layer of values
needed with this stuff
um and that if they have the right value
system they can kind of interpret things
uh in any context whether it's watching
a show or interacting with a kid on the
playground in the right way yeah
absolutely so uh getting back to the
physics and one of the topics we've
already mentioned is the potential for
energy and
um you know Limitless energy too cheap
to meter and then of course is Fusion
you know which obviously people were
very excited about last uh last December
when an announcement came out of uh out
of uh Berkeley labs uh Livermore that
they had achieved yeah net ignition and
um that this had had you know been the
culmination of billions of years and
Decades of work and you know the amount
of energy it did produce net energy
after taking everything into account you
know the actual Q factor was positive
but that's only again you know super
superimposing on it that you know
billions and trillions of extra
megajoules that they had to put this
thing together uh and resulting in the
energy required to boil you know a uh to
make a Starbucks venti latte
um uh it's important but as you also
mentioned there's a you know another
approach which is perhaps more scalable
called etar the international
thermonuclear experimental reactor it's
a European instrument in France
um you know the joke is of course they
have a nuclear fusion is the energy
source of the future it always will be
um I like to point out you know we've
had Fusion for a very long time it just
hasn't been controlled or sustainable uh
and uh I wonder how you react to elon's
you know claim that you know why do you
need you know to to generate Fusion
we've got this Fusion reactor in the in
the sky and it's uh it never goes on
strike like my graduate students did it
never you know calls in sick uh like I
often do or never catches covid so you
know why not just go all in on on solar
or hydrogen or you know something else
or even nuclear fission why are we
spending any money on this versus you
know going all in on what we know
already works and we have you know like
you have three nuclear power plants
within a you know 20 mile radius if you
have a Navy ship yard nearby as we do
here in San Diego we've got five
nuclear-powered aircraft carriers in the
harbor right now so so tell me why
should we spend any money on Fusion uh
yeah we have a perfectly working one
overhead that I like to study and we
have many many vision and other sources
of energy
I've never seen
investor technol technology investors or
technologists become luddites as quickly
as they do than when you start talking
about fuchsia
um it's really profound and I think the
reason is so many people are so what
what a poker term I'll use pot committed
they put so much money into this concept
that like Renewables are the kind of
next transition phase for energy
production on Earth and as a result guys
like Elon who's got this massive solar
battery business wants to see that
become proliferant and trillion dollars
and so on and that's all very Noble and
useful and great fission is very Noble
and useful and great and fission should
be everywhere uh we have a massive
social and kind of regulatory regime
problem
um that limits the proliferation of
fission
as you know
um getting approvals uh 30 plus years
and you know no one no one Mindy stuff
can't have it in my backyard in China
they just
um you know started the progress on
building 450 I think um half to gigawatt
uh scale system so they'll have half a
terawatt of production coming online
over the next whatever period of time
here as they build out these pigeon
reactors
um and so I'm I'm fully in support of a
vision
um but it is uh completely burdened by
this kind of a regulatory
Voyager uh voigr uh has been approved uh
the nuclear Regulatory Commission it's a
small-scale nuclear reactor I'll send
you something yeah at 76 feet but it
produces 77 megawatts of electricity and
then and then thorium is you know
basically not not really employed but
it's much safer than uranium the
traditional totally
so yeah look I by the way so so the
bigger picture point is it's not an
either or so yeah uh I I do think I you
know we can go through the kind of first
principles in the macroeconomics on
Renewables like
there's a limitation on where they can
go the there's a massive carbon deficit
to produce them right you have to mine
materials to make them make all these
renewable uh production systems yeah uh
you have to spend a bunch of money to
build and install them they're almost
completely unrecyclable in the Solar
plants they're unrecyclable and and
they're not controllable uh you have to
have as a result of kind of renewable
capacity achieving base load you then
also have to get batteries and and then
you have to mine a bunch of lithium and
uh and there's a big carbon deficit to
all the work that needs to go into
making Renewables uh you know truly
proliferate I think we've just got a
generally increase energy production uh
on Earth so we've increased energy
production by about 20 fold in the last
hundred years on Earth
um I think in the next hundred years we
can and should increase energy
production by over 100 volt so we can't
just kind of replace old systems and get
some Renewables this doesn't solve the
core driver the core driver is human
consumption and consumption means we're
replacing labor with machines you know
we're moving around stuff more there's
so much about
um the the the evolution of humans
that's driven as we talked about earlier
by this notion of Desire I have to
consume more this year than I did last
year to feel happy if I don't consume
more next year I'm not going to feel
like I'm getting happier or I'm happy
anymore I'm unhappy when I'm consuming
less this year than I did last year I I
have less so I'm consuming last time I'm
unhappy so the the core driver of human
civilization is
um is this kind of consumptive pattern
which ultimately drives up energy
consumption which means we need to make
more energy to make things more abundant
make them more affordable make them more
accessible
going yeah yeah so I don't like I think
Renewables are great to kind of do some
decarbonization in the near term great
but like they're not going to kind of
replace everything
uh fission has this regulatory so we
have to have a portfolio of stuff
um Fusion from a first principles
perspective as you know Works uh because
we see it working in the sky so we know
that this physics is real
we know
yeah I mean we we we know that the the
energy production capacity we know what
needs to go into it we know what needs
to happen
um
and uh and ultimately there's nothing
that that kind of limits um
I I'd love your point of view on this
but like I say this and people get
really like uh upset because there's no
reason that you can't have Fusion
ultimately reduced in scale to fit in a
watch there's nothing about physics that
says you can't have um a magnetic
containment field and have the necessary
kind of fuel source and the control
system in a watch there's nothing that
says physics has to be huge all
technology starts out really big
mainframes are in a basement they cost
15 million dollars they got cheaper we
all have a computer in our pocket now
that costs 600 that is probably a
hundred billion times more memory and
compute capacity than that Mainframe and
um so they get cheaper they get faster
they get better they get smaller
um Fusion is in the like you know
pre-anyiac phase right now like you know
we're kind of it's in the it's in the
coat hanger gum phase of transistor
circuitry being demonstrated
um and the the the first principles of
physics say this is possible this should
happen so a couple years ago three years
ago there was about seven
venture-funded Fusion companies
um as of the end of last year or two
three of last year that the count was 47
and I was speaking with an investor last
week who told me that the count is now
up to 70. so there are 70 Fusion
companies that are that are pursuing
different models of fusion energy
production
um as you know there's kind of the
Tokamak systems there's distillerator
systems and now there's these kind of
pulse plasma systems like helion and
others all of which have different
physics underlying kind of how they're
supposed to get the plasma to uh hot
enough and dense enough state to to
trigger kind of a sustainable or
sustaining kind of fusion
um reaction routine
um in in terms of like the uh the
tokemax it feels to me like so much of
what's driving the advantage here and
enabling them is similar to what I
talked about with DNA sequencing which
there's all these underlying digital
technologies that in aggregate are
enabling a cost down where suddenly the
potential goes up and the possibilities
or the probability of success goes up so
um
as you know like so much of like
um experimental like beam physics I used
to work in the center for beam physics
at Lawrence Berkeley labs for two years
when I was an undergrad
um and they had like a this was back in
1999 the
um uh this plasma Wakefield accelerator
and you know they were kind of uh trying
to build I think gev
um scale uh uh particle accelerators on
a bench top and a meter by you know
creating a plasma and and it's like a
femto second scale high energy laser
pulse that kind of triggers a wave that
kicks off the electron proton
accelerates yeah so in a short period of
of of physical space you can create what
would otherwise take a giant cyclotron
uh in terms of energy
um to get these particles moving and and
then use them for kind of experimental
applications research application
um and what's happened over the years I
think is that the ability to kind of
generate you know femto second scale or
subfemtosecond scale uh sensing uh
technology and control technology and
responsiveness and then the compute
infrastructure needed to actually
quickly compute and respond and drive
what the sensor is telling you and drive
an action in the chamber
um it has changed profoundly and so much
of the science is not science it's
engineering it's about the electronic
componentry
um that can very rapidly and accurately
and precisely sense and then very
accurately precisely control
um a strong enough magnetic field
um and one kind of analogy I use when
talking to people about Fusion is it's
like a giant balloon and if you put a
pin prick in the balloon all the air
gets out that's what happens with with a
fusion with a with a plasma if you
cannot um control it the plasma will
just kind of you know go away and it'll
evaporate it'll it'll all the energy
will push it out and it'll kind of go
into the walls
um not in a dangerous explosive way FYI
everybody so it just you know it's very
very low math
um and so uh so you have to kind of get
the magnetic field now the problem is as
the magnetic field closes on the plasma
right the plasma pushes back and it's
actually Dynamic how that happens and
that Dynamic nature causes everything to
kind of fall apart very often and very
frequently so you have to change it very
quickly so the the component tree the
electronic componentry the software the
digital tooling
um all of these kind of underlying
elements new semiconductor new
um a superconducting materials are
allowing us to create much stronger much
more precise and much more responsive
systems that actually make this concept
finally possible or more feasible than
it was 50 or 60 years ago when it was
kind of first theorized as being kind of
this industrial concept and as we've
kind of stepped into trying it out we're
like oh wow I gotta I gotta respond at
femto second scale to magnetic field
Distortion and then I've got to do it
with this level of a magnetic field
and if it's even slightly off it's it's
gonna the Plasma's gonna break and so
all of this ended up becoming kind of a
series of builds that were enabled by
new technologies and I think now we're
seeing this proliferation of plasma
Fusion technology Concepts that are
actually experimentally realizable that
weren't 10 years ago or 15 years or 20
years ago and that's the moment it's
like when DNA sequencing like in the
Human Genome Project stage right now
where it's 100 million dollars to
sequence the genome you know 20 years
later it's a hundred dollars and I'm
hopeful that's where we end up with with
these systems and plasma fusion and
obviously the systems that require
tritium as a fuel source are are kind of
currently you know rate limited and we
got to go get tritium and it's super
expensive and hard to source and so on
um you know there's there's theories on
how you can kind of resolve that then
there's other systems that don't use
critium and they're more attractive so
what I tell investors that call me on
this and ask me about this there's a
portfolio of 70 projects and you know
the European project the great one of
big the big bets in that board folio I'm
not going to bet on any project in that
portfolio today I have no friggin clue
which one's gonna get there when they're
gonna get there how they're going to get
there and you could be right you know
like the VHS beta you could be right
beta was better than VHS but VHS
proliferated and you know Facebook in
Myspace right so you could be right be
early and be totally uh off out of the
money tokamax accelerator pulse plasma
with lasers I don't know
across this portfolio of Beth
and from and looking at things from a
first principles perspective the money
is going in the physics says it's going
to happen the first principles make
sense all the underlying technology
Trends are supporting the probability of
success and I would guess that this
portfolio is going to yield a 95 likely
outcome of us having sustainable
low-cost fusion-driven energy in our
lifetime
um and so I'm I'm very optimistic about
where things are headed because of first
principles underlying technology and
there's a ton of different bats and it's
great when there's a ton of beds it's
great when there's tons of companies all
working on different ways of addressing
the problem and um
going back to uh first the real first
principles I'd like to submit you know
it's Oscar season right your your
parents are probably getting mailers and
DVDs
um so for your consideration uh David
with hum with humility requisite of of a
big fan of yours um for consideration
for science Corner uh scientists and
astronomers have recently uh detected
what they claim to be the first stars
ever to evolve in the universe creating
nuclear fusion so staying on that topic
um and Matt was using the James Webb
Space Telescope data they claim to have
observed a signature which would be the
Hallmark of what are called population
three stars so for the audience members
who may not be familiar uh with this
their Charmers believe we are currently
in what's called population one
confusingly and the very first start
that ever existed population three and
those were primordial gas clouds of
basically hydrogen that then coalesced
under Gravity and immense pressure
causing a ignition of the primordial
High hydrogen which is the relic of the
Big Bang which what I study the cosmic
microwave background the formation of a
molecular hydrogen or Atomic hydrogen
rather H you know just H hydrogen
but with an electron that recombination
process 380 000 years after the big bang
released the CMB that I study and
looking for its telltale signs of
earlier epochs like the synthesis of
gravitational waves and nuclei but
anyway these Stars you know have this
basic you know the simplest recipe
possible you know take hydrogen add
gravity and you get helium which is
exactly where the sun uh you know the
sun gets its name from but by the way
did you know that helium was discovered
on the sun David
the helium was discovered on the sun
yeah it was not discovered on Earth it
was discovered from the spec from the
Sun and actually astronomers had to go
there I've known that at some point yeah
yeah it's it's good yeah it was really
heroic today yeah astronomers had to go
to the Sun at night to study it you know
it's too dangerous otherwise
um no they discovered it from its
Spectrum obviously and uh that's how the
new uh fingerprint now the same thing is
happening with the very first Stars
David in the early Universe I'll send
you a link to this paper uh which is you
know tentative right now but the
signature's been long known that if you
saw a singly ionized healing so helium
has two protons uh ordinary non-isotopic
helium-3 helium-4 has two protons two
neutrons two electrons and this the
Hallmark of so-called population three
the very first Stars would be the
observation of the spectral
characteristics of a singly ionized
helium atoms in the early universe and
the astronomers claim that they've seen
this and there have been claims before
but this one is now using basically the
the one of the two main goals of the
James Rose face telescope was to really
illuminate no pun intended the era of
recumb of realonization and the first
stars to ever ignite by this process so
that would be population three and um
it's really quite fascinating to me that
this could be really the the first light
in the universe not from the primordial
realm but of ordinary objects that then
provide the seed Capital uh to then
create the stars that created the the
Supernova that existed in our solar
system and our that caused our solar
system to create of which here's a
fragment here I'm going to send you one
of these David as I do to all my uh
listeners who have a edu email address
and sign up for my mailing list at Brian
keating.com list but these are fragments
of the of the nuclear explosion of
population two that then provided the
seed Capital as I say for population one
so it's an extremely uh inspiring thing
uh that we're living in you know this
recently was released last week
basically the claim of these data so I
want to ask you
um uh unless you have any thoughts on
that as a as a possible uh Contender for
a future science Corner
um uh where where you you know kind of
would go now if you were um if you could
go back and and talk to the David of uh
2001 you graduated from Cal
um what would you advise sort of uh you
know similarly or differently we're
getting into the phase I call the the
existential question phase
but the name of the podcast is Into The
Impossible and that's from an Arthur C
Clarke quote which says the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to venture Beyond them into the
impossible and I use that as a
springboard to kind of get advice to uh
to their former selves and my guests and
let me ask you if you go back to that 20
or 21 22 year old David Friedberg 2001
graduate of Cal what would you tell them
to do similarly differently to give him
the courage to do as you've done to go
into the impossible
advice to your former self
yeah it's hard to I'm sorry but it's
really hard to rewrite I um my
Meandering path like everyone's got us
to where we are today and
um
you know there's nothing about today
that I would say I would want to have be
different in terms of my outlook for
tomorrow which is all I can really do
with today
um
and so it's hard to say I I will tell
people that I've had extraordinary
diversity in experiences uh in my career
and in my um
uh my kind of life and uh you know the
integration of those experiences the
synthesis of them
um has been really important Steve Jobs
did such a good job with that
commencement speech that he gave where
he said you know take a he took a
calligraphy class and the calligraphy
class led him to
um
having a uh point of view that they
should have fonts on the original
Macintosh which was one of the kind of
defining features of the graphical user
interface in the original MacIntosh and
really kind of revolutionized the
personal Computing industry and it was
because he explored this kind of
unrelated interest at the moment that
that got him into that
um my uh infrared astronomy lab as an
undergrad
um gave me exposure to you know cooling
down the CCD camera and getting the data
out of it manipulating the data and kind
of connecting everything from how are we
collecting photons on this device all
the way through to the data and
computation that uh computation of the
data that comes off that device then the
interpretation of it that gave me a
perspective that wasn't applicable in my
personal Endeavors to go and research
using infrared telescopes but gave me a
set of tools and understandings that
informed my ability to kind of do
programming later because I used IDL at
the time or uh to understand how these
sensors work to understand how DNA
sequence thing work to understand how
much of
how data and information kind of
manipulation with matrices worked that
was super useful to me later on in my
career when working in software
um and I I can give kind of a lot of
different examples but I just encourage
everyone to not be kind of linear and
and unitrack in their
um in their their work and their
research in their exploration of
interest uh but to really kind of be
intellectually curious and explore and
try and do and learn in lots of
different ways
you never know how things are going to
kind of fit together later that's always
the big surprise
um yeah and that's been the case for me
time and time again in my life is
um my ability to kind of take the next
step often has been driven from some
insight I drew from some experience I
had that was totally unrelated to any
track I'm on today from in the past and
then realized some outcome so yeah yeah
kicker guards I mean yeah I would
probably spend more time in
you know bioengineering programming
computer science programming later but
honestly like uh you know when in 2003 I
I was kind of working at this job that I
worked at for under a year and I taught
myself
um programming and PHP MySQL uh setting
up a Linux server Apache server uh like
I built the whole stack on a JavaScript
and I built this kind of web service
this this app called uh kadango which is
like a question on answer research
service and it was like I was working
till four in the morning every night and
then at 8 AM I'd be in the office again
and I would get home and I would work on
it all night and I you know and I kept I
read all the books on computer
programming wrote the whole thing myself
built a payment Gateway integration uh
set up an AdWords account bought ads
this was back in 2013. advertised got
all these people using it made money
from it the whole kind of stack of the
experience got me a job at Google and I
would have never gotten a job at Google
uh with the experience that I had had
without having done that on my own and
having kind of explored that work on my
own
um and so I think like yeah that's sort
of like exploration of interest and just
trying new things was so important um in
kind of charting my path forward yeah
yeah I always love the quote by uh Sarah
and Kierkegaard who said uh you know
life you can only be understood looking
backwards but you have to live it going
forwards obviously did you know Andy
Friedman
um who was a Cal uh grad I think either
a year before you or perhaps two years
before you he worked with Alex too
um he uh was a strong man
yeah unfortunately yeah he he passed
away about two years ago from a rare I'm
sorry yeah lymphoma
um so uh pivoting to another existential
question if you've got a couple more
minutes that I always love to ask it's
really prompted by a quote that you
almost uh presaged earlier today which
is one from Arthur C Clarke the namesake
of the institution that I associate lead
direct I guess you'd say which is that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic if you had
to put on a monolith like in 2001 you
know kind of the summary of the greatest
achievements of the human brain
um what would you put on it you know as
sort of a time capsule to have a little
bit of bravado Swagger for the human
race in terms of an intellectual or
technological or or even artistic
Triumph that human beings have been able
to make that would last maybe for a
billion years
[Music]
the one or the many things you could do
as many as you like
um man that's a tough one I don't know
the answer to that
um
yeah I mean there's certainly a lot of
principles in mathematics and physics uh
Feynman Feynman said it was the atomic
hypothesis that he wasn't a guest on the
show unfortunately but but if Simon said
you know the thing that encapsulates the
most amazing amount of detail in the
shortest amount of words is that
everything is made of atoms and these
atoms have you know structures
substructures being on them that are
governed by forces and Fields
um I always turn into cosmology and
suffer but I've had people turn into
um to you know philosophy and theology
even in Nancy you know and Julian who's
Carl Sagan's widow she said you know
she'd put on the monolith you know
basically
um uh you know act humbly walk uh act
justly walk humbly with without your God
she doesn't believe in God but quote
from Mika in the Old Testament
um so yeah the the kind of you know
magical technology there's something
about obviously that that infatuates you
with technology I think I don't know
what could be more profound that humans
have kind of come across all things
related to physics we can kind of in
mathematics we can kind of resolve
through
I don't want to say rudimentary but like
or Elementary but like yeah yeah I love
Elementary experimentation and
demonstration quantum mechanics is just
and remains to be the the mind-blowing
transition of like
all of physics like you know the
um and the demonstrations and
um in experimental
quantum physics um
uh probably have created the greatest
transition for uh you know our
interaction with the physical Universe
uh and it continues to be not just
profound but
um staggeringly challenging to kind of
understand and connect and the
extensions into Quantum field Theory uh
I there's there's this kind of like
I don't want to say well I think the
appropriate term is human uncertainty or
physical you know
um uncertainty about our ability to
fully grasp and and conceptualize
uh that
within which we are
uh which we are within um
uh and and are fitting with it and um
yeah I was thinking the other day what
was I watching I was watching um
some movie
and I was like this guy if he relived
this day he could have done it better
and then I was thinking about Groundhog
Day happy Groundhog Day again and then I
was like but every day that the
individual arrived if you could reboot a
day over and over again and and and
optimize and improve it would all the
conditions be the same in that day and
the idea of being like look you could
always kind of if you could capture the
the the location and the motion or the
velocity the vector of every particle in
the universe could you be perfectly
predictive about what's going to happen
in the universe
um and then there's ways you can kind of
disprove that to be the case using
um content mechanics and then I was
thinking if I got dropped into the same
day over and over again would everything
happen the same way that day every time
I lived through it
um because my my presence in it with new
knowledge or new information changes the
quantum field of that universe and so
that Universe maybe the the the formula
of or the the parameters of that that
Quantum field is the state of the
universe encompassing both space and
time and the Observer am I and the
Observer an observer and as a result the
fact that I've observed a a day means
that I cannot maybe observe the same set
of conditions happening in day two
because I've already observed them in
day one so can I really go relive the
same day over and over again uh and it
really kind of struck me like that that
that higher order concept that maybe
there is a dimensionality that that you
know it's very hard for a human brain to
fully grok and I think you know quantum
mechanics and the output to experience
certain experiments maybe give us a
sliver of an insight into how how
profound that is you know I don't know
yeah no that's that that is of course
the most mysterious thing and then the
question of whether or not you know we
could have a truly have a gut not the
Super gut kind but the grand unified
theory you know remains a mystery if we
can actually unify the the three lower
four or no higher energy forces strong
weak and electromagnetic forces with
gravity is a theory of everything that's
even possible
um next I want to ask you to look into
your crystal ball not not necessarily a
billion years into the future but but
just to the biblical age of 120 uh when
Moses our Rabbi Moses uh failed to reach
the promised land hopefully we'll we'll
reach the promised land but I want to
ask you he wrote What's called the Zava
ethical will which is an encapsulation
of wisdom not in his monetary you know
you know munificence that he's going to
bestow but but I want to ask you what
would what would be sort of something
that you'd put in an ethical will when
you reach that 80 years hence from now
um uh what sort of wisdom are are
learnings and experiential uh philosophy
have you developed so far that you could
see being of value not just to your
biological children but to your
ideological children of which there are
many around the world
[Music]
yeah unfortunately I think a lot of the
sage wisdom is lost when it's just
transcribed into a single sentence or
statement and it's so much more
importantly learned through experience
or through meditation
um and it really is predominantly driven
by the loss of ego and the loss of ego
in the sense of space and time and
selflessness and so on
um is is you know the ultimate kind of
ethical Pursuit I believe of a conscious
intelligent body uh or code or should be
it manifests in lots of ways like being
giving uh you know being selfless
helping others uh having empathy
um recognizing that one's own
contributions to to the world are are
um
are going to come and are going to go
very quickly uh you know um not getting
torn up and broken up by certain things
and there is no one that
fully you know encompasses the loss of
ego
um and uh you know the uh the ability to
kind of
uh get there can be written and has been
written in many different ways
um you know it's uh it is I think
ultimately the thing that has made
humans
um as we kind of view these biological
masses we call humans like the the quote
you know best energy absorbers although
we could argue that maybe we're not
um you know but we think we are on this
planet But but so proliferant uh is our
sense of ego or desire to consume and to
to to find our place in the world in the
universe and has allowed us to manifest
knowledge and the form of engineering
and so on and change the universe around
us and get things we want
um so it's very powerful it's also very
destructive and it leads to unhappiness
and it leads to hurt and War and despair
and so on
um
and so it's it's very hard to say if all
humans abandon their ego abandoned ego
that we as a species would not lose out
on the ability to continue to accumulate
knowledge and engineer things around us
to improve and so perhaps there's a
balance of ego destruction or having
some perspective there on having empathy
and being caring and being having a
sense of Ethics around
um selflessness uh that can perhaps be
used to better motivate us to do the
things we intend to do yeah it's
beautiful yeah it's a famous coffee
Rabbi I think his name is hayim bardicha
they said that a man should carry around
in his uh Pockets two pieces of paper in
one pocket it says the universe was made
for me which is a quote from Genesis and
the other one is another quote from
Genesis I am nothing but dust and Ashes
now balancing that that that the balance
is always so hard right David to it's
easy to be polarized and I love the fact
that you on on your uh you know show you
your your your radical moderate in that
you're not interested in the political
polarization so much you're interested
in the talk list the the core facts and
and the Heart of the issue but it's very
difficult to be in the middle right
there's a Yiddish proverb that he who
stands in the middle of the road gets
hit by traffic from both sides of the
street
um but I want to commend you for that
and um what other besides the into the
impossible podcast what else is on your
uh daily driving rotation what do you
listen to besides uh your own show and
and hopefully the into the impossible
podcast
obviously goes deep and um yeah uh you
know spends quite a bit of time with his
with his guests to enjoy it I actually
just do a lot of audible books so my my
biggest thing is uh I find it uh I've
issues with my my vision
um so I have a hard time reading
physical books lately uh so I'm I listen
to a lot of audible books so I'll take
long walk through while I'm driving uh
listed audible books and try and crank
through them uh mix of fiction and
non-fiction so I'm kind of all over the
place believe it or not I'm in my My
Bravo TV Real Housewives moment right
now I'm listening to the Prince Harry
book spare uh yeah I I yeah it audible
promoted it to me and I'm like okay I'll
give it a shot I put it on I have no
interest whatsoever in the Royals or
anything I put it on in the car the
other day I was thinking I give it five
minutes and because it was like a free
promotion like and then I'm just like
listening to the guy I'm like this is
basically like eighth grade writing but
it's super like like it's super
addictive and compelling and I like it
is yeah my wife caught me watching your
Netflix show I was like oh I'm watching
a Fowler I'm watching Fowler no no honey
I'm gonna put it in the chat line zero I
have zero Palace entry I have zero
intros I don't know any of them the
cultural references yeah but um no I
don't know why it was just like it's
cotton candy you know sometimes you need
a you need to drink an actual
sugar-filled Coke I'm putting in the
chat a link to a book that I know you're
gonna love called the mind of a bee uh
by Lars uh chitgo's a a researcher I
think in in Europe but he kind of
presents from you know it's the classic
Nagel uh you know can you what is it
like to be a bat
um but it's written from the perspective
of perhaps the the
um uh ingestation of new sensory kind of
uh uh perceptions that we could develop
as human beings you know like not just
neural link or whatever but what if we
are kind of like a blind man in the
forest or you know holding the elephant
we don't have these we don't have these
tools that a bee has and yet you know
bees have co-evolved with humans for you
know literally 50 000 years they found
it with Neanderthals Denise events they
found like honey and and it's the most
calorically rich
substance that's naturally available in
the world before you know Coca-Cola and
high fructose corn syrup and so how do
their brains actually react and you know
it's a model for how humans can be and
also
um you know Collective hive mind Network
I know you're going to love the
audiobook is awesome my kids even my my
12 year old loves it
um okay last question before we we break
and our bladder burst from this three
hour almost interview
um
yeah it's been 2 32 232 but hopefully we
can get we can keep we can keep going
for a few more minutes
um the final question I like to ask is
also pertinent and it comes from uh uh
Sir Arthur I got mine of a bee lined up
by the way all good yeah you're gonna
love it uh if you don't your money I'll
pay you back for it
um uh I'm gonna hope to have him on the
podcast because he's just a great writer
um
um so Arthur C Clarke said another thing
he's had a lot of cool things he said
you know for every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert it you know
which kind of reminds me of Fineman said
science is the belief in the ignorance
of experts not in the wisdom you know if
if Newton had been the final word he
would never have been questioned by
Einstein right and we'd be stuck with
you know with uh you know instantaneous
gravitational transport but anyway
another thing that that
um that uh Sir Arthur said was when an
elderly but distinguished scientist says
something is possible he is very
probably right but when an elderly but
distinguished scientist is something is
impossible is most likely wrong
I'm not calling you elderly or you know
about a decade younger than me but um
what have you changed your mind about
what have you been wrong about is there
anything that you've you know come maybe
been a little bit humbled by which I I
always find if you search in Google
which you you know you work with Larry a
while back but if you search in like the
following phrase it was the best thing
that ever happened to me David the most
likely words to appear before that I did
this once are I got fired or you know
she broke up with me or you know
something something that would in the
moment seem seem negative yeah I know
it's true for me I got fired from
Stanford University as a postdoc ended
up now I'm talking to you and then the
through line is is completely clear in
retrospect but have you been wrong or
have you had something that you've
learned about that in the moment maybe
you were you were convinced you couldn't
be wrong about but you actually you know
in retrospect have learned from this
this uh this situation where perhaps you
were you know had a lot of cognitive
bias towards believing you were correct
foreign
[Music]
I I generally totally agree with the
sentiment that you know we have to hold
both views in our mind this is also why
I'm very boring if I had a podcast on my
own no one would listen to it because
I'm not stimulating with a strong
prediction or an extreme statement uh
one way or the other and I think
stepping up a level and viewing the
bigger picture is more important to
thinking about
uh the reality of things again going
back to dualism it's not one or the
other it's all it's both and
um in some cases it's a probability
going back to Quantum Mechanics it's a
probability distribution function of
things that may happen
um
and uh you know I often kind of think
this way about the things that may
happen
uh you know being a likelihood of
happening we used to do these um uh uh
you know when you build like a software
based model you're predicting an output
uh you're predicting an event and when
you train a model
you build a reliability plot if you want
to visualize how accurate the model is
in the reliability plot on the x-axis is
uh you know how frequently does the
model say something is likely to happen
and the y-axis is how frequently did
those events actually happen so if each
one goes from zero to 100 and all of
these models follow an S curve the the
reliability plot of nearly any
predictive model at some point at some
point in the history of the universe
will resolve to some s-curve and it will
result to an s-curve because the things
that the model says will never happen
happen with some degree of frequency and
the things that the model says will
always happen will happen with some
degree of frequency there is no such
thing as 100 or zero percent uh you know
kind of predictive um that power so um
so so that that that's I think like a
really important General kind of
orientation I try and make sure I remind
myself of as often as I can so I don't
get in trouble uh being 100 convinced or
zero percent convinced of things
um and now in in my particular life I
um
you know I'm not
I'm not fully sure
um there's a lot I've learned about
um
how how much
humans can be convinced of things and
polarized into things that I did not
really appreciate when I was younger
um
and there's a binary nature here's a
good one um
probably kind of
um
the idea that there is
and I know most people hold this belief
in some Realm that there is some
nefarious Central force or power that is
influencing and doing things in a
negative way that is that is oriented
around evil
um that these people are bad and they
know they're being bad and they're doing
it to be bad and I think the thing that
I've really been convinced of
is that so many people
um
make decisions that
are really in their mind decisions for
good when they may actually just be
make sure this thing's still is it still
recording yeah yeah I lost it for one
second yeah sorry my headphones died um
but uh yeah actually like
uh decisions that may in some cases be
adverse for some groups and maybe viewed
that way and for some groups maybe are
being viewed another way but the core
motivation of nearly everyone is that
they're doing good things for good
reasons like that's just that yeah
we have this narrative yeah no I love
what you said earlier you know that that
we have this narrative and we can
backfill in and you can talk about what
your wealth is going to do and but it's
it's it's this it's survivability by
it's Survivor by I mean yeah you're at
this point but you're gonna backfill The
Narrative because that's what we do and
you're going to make yourself portrayed
in the best light that's that's why I
like to ask the question because you
know part of being a scientist is is
being wrong all the time and I imagine
as an investor as an entrepreneur
you know you're going to be wrong it's a
power law you're like your best your
best possible you know uh ideas are
gonna result in in the 10x return but
there's going to be 10x fewer of them
right so so we're going to be wrong and
to say well you know I I don't you know
to not learn from your mistakes is is is
you know I think it's the sign of
someone can't get to where you are you
know hopefully where I am without having
to make a mistake way more mistakes than
evil person I think there's something
about the human mind in a social system
that orients around there is some
element in control that is keeping me
from having things I want and then so
much of politics and social engineering
and business is all about get wrestling
control away from that which is in power
um and it is the ever kind of
evolutionary cycle of social systems
um between humans every and again going
back to this point about individual
desire I want things I don't have today
and I rationalize that there is someone
or something that is keeping me from
having those things because I don't have
them today if I don't have them today
something's wrong something's unfair
something's unjust someone is holding it
that someone else has the thing I want
and there's some reason that the system
that the social system that I have to be
a part of has made that the case so what
happens in politics is there's often a
manipulation around identifying the
things that people think they don't have
um or that they want that they don't
have and then rationalizing that the
reason you don't have it is X and then
manifesting a political platform around
I'm going to get you X now vote for me
and I'll go be the person that will get
it for you and that's so much of
politics right and it's also so much of
human behavior it's like I want to build
this business because I want to have
more wealth because I want to do this
thing and I have to go wrestle that
money away from the big evil Corporation
or the food system is controlled by X or
the banking system is controlled by X
there's some reason I don't have X and
that reason is some
um you know kind of system or person or
or entity that has control and power
over me and that is so much of like the
human uh Dynamic and again it relates to
Ego because your ego is challenged
because there's something bigger and
more powerful than you and so your ego
is threatened into you your ego wants to
kind of flash out and attack and and go
after it right
it's the anti-authoritarian influence
it's like we are losing agency which the
only thing we control are these
chemicals that we call our brain you
know people always mock me or you know
often mock me because I I am a you know
practicing Jew I may not be you know the
most about you but but you know why do
you study this you know this thing
written by Bronze Age peasants and what
can you learn about you know cosmology
from I'm like well first of all there's
only like 35 sentences out of 35 000
total verses in the in the Torah in the
Old Testament have anything plausibly to
do with the creation of the universe and
it's obviously not a science book if
that's the case if you had a book and
you know if this book the mind of the
bee you know has one page out of a
thousand about the mind of a b and the
rest of it's about like the Oliver North
trial or something you know you're gonna
be what the hell is this the is
it's not accurate uh advertisement but
there's one scene as you as you put as
you just mentioned maybe think about
there's a rebellion by karak who is one
of Moses's you know cousins basically a
fellow Levi and he says exactly what you
say he's like it's too much for you you
want this control and like who said you
know who put you in charge God like
literally and then he organizes this
whole like test and how can you find out
you know if I if people should follow me
and most people are going to follow
korok who is the rebellious the rebel
against Moses and it took a miracle for
God to show that you know whether or not
you believe that but it's deeply
ingrained in human nature to rebel
against this this notion of I am not an
agent over my own control and I think
that's what gives meditation you know
such such you know such a benefit and
I'm horrible at that you know I like you
know have have an app set up that
screams at me if I if I start thinking
about something that's not my Mantra you
know I actually have the honor of having
Deepak Chopra gave me a mantra and it's
it's actually a nice one is Shalom uh
but I thought he was going to tell me
it's schmuck and I should just use that
as a mantra but but at any rate yeah
surrendering ego is the hardest thing to
do and because you need a little bit of
swagger to be a good scientist to be a
good inventor to be a good father but
it's that basis not standing in the
middle of the road and not getting hit
by traffic and yeah I just want to thank
you uh so much David for sharing so much
of your valuable time you'll send me a
bill for it later I hope
um but it's a great joy and I hope we
can meet in person someday uh they're up
there down here or wherever in the
middle that uh we can meet but I want to
thank you uh anything you uh that I want
to ask you one last question which is
what uh I'm sure there's millions of
questions that you uh get asked that
you're sick of asking get getting asked
about is there anything no one's ever
asked you about that you're like really
interested to talk about
um not just me I mean I I probably
failed enormously throughout this
conversation but many things that you'd
like are really interested in that
people don't know I mean I didn't know
how meditation impacted your life you
know as it's clear that it does
um and I can recommend some some uh some
colleagues and friends in that space too
if you're interested uh but are there
any things that you know most people
don't think to ask you well I mean the
stuff we talked about today is stuff we
never talk about I never like human
consciousness and and the impracticality
of aliens physically visiting you know
uh
other planets and gallic you know solar
systems and so on within a Galaxy or
other galaxies and
um so much of the stuff today stuff you
know it's never a great Forum to talk
about it's actually kind of fun stuff I
think about a lot or geek out on a lot
um so no that was the sort of stuff that
I would always be like more interested
in having conversations these kind of
deeper more interesting things about
you know where are we what are we where
are we headed
yeah it's the it's the reason you know
that makes us really human right that we
can think about the meaning and we're
the only species that's what Homo Sapien
means it's the one who has knowledge
that he is going to die and I think yeah
we we get so lost in the like the
materialism and the and the you know
wealth creation or scientific creation
and so forth yeah we don't have as much
time and it's almost shunned upon to
think about like the meaning of life or
theology or philosophy even in physics
is derided often so yeah I love it I
always say a podcast isn't as an excuse
for me to talk to people I want to talk
to rather than people I have to talk to
some contractor in Chile at 17 000 feet
uh let me let me switch over really
quick just in case I'll send you a zoom
link well here's a link to that um
here's a link to that
um first star population three paper oh
great and then here's a link to my book
I'm going to send you a physical I'll
send some to Rachel or to Mary
um I have a couple of meteorites I have
a moon rock for you and um and some
other swag from the Simon's Observatory
I guess we could wrap it up here today
it's been great talking to you it's so
much fun like I said I hope we do get to
meet I'll be such a blast um yeah yeah
when I'm downtown
I think San Diego kind of
uh
down there from Canada time to have
friends down there so I'll let you I'll
let you know we'll we'll grab a coffee
yeah please we can get some both of them
here we can get kosher Bolton here well
you won't need it what the hell am I
talking about oh you're the wrong guy
that's right we'll go to some stuff all
right so um yeah I'll send you my email
in here if you want to shoot me an email
anytime and then my phone here's my
phone yeah so just Alex yeah we did an
event for The seti Institute
um at uh at Palo uh one of the colleges
in pal like right near Stanford about
two years right before the pandemic we
did a podcast for them and uh yeah he's
he's a great friend and and uh it's just
such a such a I have to get him on the
podcast but you know he's he's such a
great teacher what I love about him is
you know I'm I'm more kind of all
focused on on the research and just I
have 120 million dollar projected on the
pi oven on just like every day I'm
dealing with like either contractors
that won't perform or you know diesel
fuel that won't get delivered and then
we've been recently getting robbed at
the site by people stealing coax cable
and fiber and stuff uh the it's kind of
a second world country Chile I don't
know if you've ever been there but it's
it's not quite a first world country
even though they've got a lot of
scientific development there
um okay great yeah so uh great be in
touch it'll take me a couple of weeks
probably to edit this uh kind of a
one-man shop down here but I have
luckily one guy will help me out one of
my students I I have the benefit of
having student interns which is super
fun that's great all right Dave it's
been a pleasure yeah I'd love to geek
out about God and stuff too and if you
ever uh like I said we'd love to host
you for Shabbat all right my friend well
great talking to you bye
[Music]